je suis heureuse de souhaiter en votre
nom la bienvenue à une délégation de
l'association inter parlementaire Canada
France conduite par sa présidence madame
Marie-France Lalonde bienvenue à vous
[Applaudissements]
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
d'entre elles va être posée par Monsieur
Olivier Falorni pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie voulue par
le président de la République a répondu
dimanche à la question que vous lui
aviez posé le 9 décembre dernier
à travers 146 propositions cette
convention citoyenne à exprimer très
clairement et très précisément sa
volonté de voir évoluer notre cadre
légal actuel et je tiens ici à saluer le
travail remarquable grâce à l'appui du
Conseil économique social et
environnementale de ces 184 citoyens
tirés au sort et représentatif de la
diversité de notre société
184 citoyens de tous âges et de toutes
conditions qui ont accepté de consacrer
27 journées durant 9 sessions de
participer à une réflexion collective
sur ce sujet majeur ils ont affirmé avec
force la nécessité de renforcer les
soins palliatifs pour tous et partout
sur le territoire et ils ont exprimé une
demande forte à une très large majorité
c'est à dire plus de 76% que soit
autorisé en France l'aide active à
mourir sur certaines conditions comme
par exemple
l'incurabilité de la maladie le
pronostic vital engagé les souffrances
réfractaires et la volonté réitérer du
malade sans oublier la clause de
conscience des soignants alors madame la
Première ministre je souhaitais tout
simplement vous demander quelle suite
entendez-vous donner
à ce message fort qui a été exprimé
par cette très belle convention
citoyenne je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Olivier Falorni
il y a peu de sujets plus complexes plus
délicat plus sensible que la fin de vie
pour que toutes les opinions puissent
s'exprimer et que des consensus puissent
émerger le président de la République
avait fait le choix de ne pas trancher
le débat lors de la campagne électorale
mais de le laisser se tenir dans la
société c'est le sens de la Convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie que j'avais
lancée en décembre dernier avec les
ministres Agnès Firma le Baudot et
Olivier Véran cette convention a permis
à toutes les opinions de s'exprimer
assumer des points de divergence et de
consensus de convergence et de consensus
sans passer sous silence les désaccords
comme la souligner hier le président de
la République cette convention a enrichi
nos pratiques démocratiques et débouchés
sur un rapport de grande qualité qui
nourrira les débats sur la fin de vie
dans les prochains mois en parallèle
d'autres consulter consultations et
travaux ont été menés pour éclairer le
gouvernement les parlementaires et le
débat public je pense au débat organisé
sous l'égide du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique aux échanges que nous
avons eu avec les associations les
soignants les patients et l'ensemble des
cultes ou encore à la mission
d'évaluation transpartisanes que vous
avez présidé monsieur le député Olivier
Falorni sur la loi kless Leonetti et je
veux à cet égard saluer la qualité de
vos analyses et de vos recommandations
tous ces travaux ont fait avancer notre
réflexion collective hors des clivages
partisans ils ont abouti à deux
conclusions fortes sur lesquelles nous
souhaitons avancer ensemble comme l'a
annoncé hier le président de la
République
la première conclusion c'est la
nécessité de renforcer d'urgence l'offre
de soins palliatifs nous allons donc
lancer une stratégie pour améliorer
significativement la prise en charge de
la douleur et l'accès aux soins
palliatifs
la seconde conclusion
issue des travaux de la convention
citoyenne c'est la nécessité d'inventer
un modèle français de la fin de vie
notre cadre législatif n'est plus adapté
notamment pour aborder le sujet de
l'aide active à mourir sur l'importance
du discernement sur l'incurabilité sur
les souffrances physiques réfractaires
les premiers contours ont été posés et
le travail doit continuer
collectivement nous devons nous saisir
des conclusions de la convention
citoyenne ensemble nous construirons un
projet de loi qui sera déposé d'ici la
fin de l'été je souhaite que la
préparation de ce texte associe
largement toutes les forces politiques
mais également les soignants les
associations et les représentants des
patients
mesdames et messieurs les députés face à
un sujet aussi grave nous avons sombre
avec humanité et humilité nous avons à
coeur de bâtir une réponse qui trouve
qui trouve un soutien très large dans un
esprit de Concorde et de rassemblements
nous y parviendrons ensemble je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Alain David
pour le groupe socialiste
question s'adresse c'est madame la
Première ministre en dépit de vos temps
en dépit de vos tentatives de
pourrissement le front syndical reste
solide et les organisations syndicales
du pays restent mobilisés avec constance
et détermination
tandis qu'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation aura lieu jeudi les
syndicats vous rappellent leur
opposition résolue au passage de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
comme la nouvelle secrétaire général de
la CGT Sophie Binet dont je salue
l'élection à la tête de la centrale
la rappeler le retrait de cette réforme
et la seule solution pour ouvrir le
dialogue et apaiser le pays
votre projet est condamné par une
écrasante majorité de nos concitoyens
refusés par les partenaires sociaux et
ne disposent d'aucune majorité politique
vous conduisant ainsi à l'usage du 49-3
les présidents Valo et kaner se rendent
aujourd'hui avec les autres groupes de
la nuit devant le Conseil
constitutionnel afin d'exposer nos
arguments juridiques suite au recours
déposés par les députés et les sénateurs
de gauche nous poursuivrons nous députés
notre mobilisation ici et dans nos
circonscriptions contre ce projet de
réforme des retraites aussi injustes
socialement
inefficace économiquement
la colère sociale monte et les
préoccupations sur le pouvoir d'achat
devrait inciter le gouvernement à
s'attaquer aux problèmes quotidiens de
nos concitoyens plutôt que de braquer
toute la société contre une réforme
inique il vous appartient d'entendre le
message des Françaises et des Français
vous ne pouvez les ignorer plus
longtemps madame la Première ministre
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
à nouveau dans le débat c'est la raison
pour laquelle demain la première
ministre recevra l’inter syndicale pour
évoquer l'ensemble des sujets et
Monsieur le Député vous avez à
l'occasion de votre question souligner
que le week-end dernier est un week-end
d'élection vous savez saluer l'élection
de la nouvelle secrétaire général de la
CGT madame Binet je m'associe à vos
salutations j'en sais j'en profite aussi
pour saluer l'élection d'une nouvelle
députée Martine Froget dans l'Ariège à
qui je souhaite bienvenue dans cette
Assemblée nationale
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
Monsieur David non
la parole est à madame Béatrice
des camps pour le groupe yote merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
personnes handicapées madame la ministre
pour protecteur qu'il soit l'amendement
Creton a pour effet de maintenir en
établissement spécialisé pour enfants
des jeunes adultes ayant dépassé la
limite d'âge administrative de 20 ans et
en attente de place en structure pour
adultes actuellement pas de structure
adaptée beaucoup de ces jeunes restent
en IME jusqu'à 28 ans parfois
il développa un mal-être des troubles du
comportement ou des absences à
répétition
parallèlement l'accueil prolongé des
plus âgés en IME bloque l'arrivée des
plus jeunes les prix vent d'une prise en
charge indispensable cette organisation
pose par ailleurs d'importantes aux
équipes qui doivent démultiplier l'offre
d'activités éducatives et de soutien
médico-sociaux
ainsi que les difficultés juridiques que
peu engendrer la cohabitation entre
enfants mineurs et jeunes adultes conçus
à l'origine comme un dispositif
transitoire l'amendement Creton ne
permet que de décaler les ruptures de
parcours et les retours à domicile sans
accompagnement les familles que je
rencontre régulièrement souffrent plus
encore lorsqu'elle voit leurs enfants
devenir adolescents car elles savent que
dans quelques années il n'y aura pas de
réponse adaptées pour eux j'ai
d'ailleurs une pensée ici pour ces
mamans de jeunes autistes que j'ai reçu
tout récemment et je précise madame la
ministre que j'évoque ici les jeunes
pour lesquels les solutions alternatives
ne sont pas envisageables aujourd'hui
rappelons-le il faut attendre 10 à 15
ans pour avoir une place dans un
établissement pour adulte madame la
ministre quelle piste constez-vous
suivre pour réduire ces déséquilibres et
apporter des réponses concrètes assez
familles et à ces jeunes je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Geneviève darrieussec ministre des
personnes handicapées
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée vous posez une question
importante et difficile
les adultes en établissement d'enfants
pour moi c'est non et n'ont rien à y
faire donc nous devons être très
proactif pour faire en sorte de changer
la situation changer la situation ne se
fera pas un jour soyons tous honnêtes
dans tout ce que nous voulons partager
se fera effectivement en fonction des
besoins de ces personnes certaines
peuvent rentrer dans l'emploi il en
existe d'autres peuvent d'autres ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans l'emploi mais
doivent avoir des accompagnements
spécifiques voire des structures
spécifiques je souhaite que chaque cas
soit évalué individuellement et que nous
trouvions des réponses pour répondre à
ce sujet qui est effectivement un sujet
important puisqu'il nous empêche nous
contraints
dans les places d'ime réservées aux
jeunes et l'accès à ces nécessaire pour
des jeunes sont bloqués donc nous avons
devant nous un vrai travail que la CNH
j'espère la prochaine Conférence
nationale du handicap nous permettra et
nous donnera les moyens de pouvoir
travailler dans ce sens évaluer plus
précocement les jeunes dans leur
capacité leur compétences les mettre en
formation plus précocement et faire en
sorte de pouvoir avoir un trajet de
sortie de saisie émeuts qui soit un
trajet
d'où vers les esats ou vers le travail
en milieu ordinaire c'est ça l'ambition
et pour les cas les plus complexes avoir
des solutions à l'institution je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à madame Claire Guichard
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche j'y associe mes collègues Anne
bruniera et Christine le nabourg ont
gageait de longues dates sur ce sujet
merci dernier vous lanciez la première
étape de la réforme des aides sociales
étudiantes merci pour cette promesse
tenue pour autant l'État n'a pas attendu
pour soutenir et accompagner ses
étudiants certains semblent l'avoir
oublié mais c'est bien un autre majorité
qui est en pleine période de covid a mis
en place le repas 1 euro c'est notre
majorité qu'il a étendu à tous les
étudiants boursiers ainsi qu'à tous les
étudiants précaires qui ont font la
demande via le CROUS c'est encore et
toujours notre majorité qui a modifié un
barème qui n'avait pas évolué depuis 10
ans cette réforme c'est le fruit d'une
concertation engagée depuis octobre par
le gouvernement avec l'ensemble des
organisations représentatives étudiantes
ce sont 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour nos étudiants dès
la rentrée universitaire 2023 jamais en
disant l'État n'avait autant investi
pour aider sa jeunesse c'est historique
ces nouvelles mesures répondent à
l'objectif fixé par le président de la
République le coût de la vie ne sera
plus jamais une barrière aux études
le premier étudiants supplémentaires
issus des classes moyennes qui
deviendront boursiers à la rentrée se
rajoutant ainsi au plus de 700
000 boursiers actuels pour tout cela les
frais d'inscription seront gratuits et
ils ne paieront pas la CVC il
bénéficieront du repas un euro et seront
prioritaires pour un logement au CROUS
12 aidons les jeunes en augmentant le
montant des bourses pour tous les
échelons à 37 euros nous aidons nos
jeunes 140000 boursiers actuels
basculeront un échelon de bourse
supérieur prenons ainsi pleinement en
compte leur situation familiale 66 à 127
euros de plus par mois parce que ces
étudiants sont notre avenir madame la
ministre pouvez-vous ce jour nous dire
comment s'organisera la seconde étape de
cette consultation je vous remercie ma
chère collègue
la parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la Présidente messieurs mesdames
les députés mesdames la députée claire
Guichard tout d'abord merci beaucoup
merci pour votre question qui me permet
effectivement de revenir sur ces
réformes des bourses cette première
partie et sur ce que le gouvernement et
cette majorité fait pour les étudiants
alors en effet nous avons voulu faire
plus pour les étudiants comme vous
l'avez dit ce seront à la rentrée 2023
plus d'étudiants 35000 nouveaux
boursiers et c'est 35000 nouveaux
boursiers ils pourront toucher 145 euros
par mois en plus des avantages que vous
avez cité et puis nous avons voulu faire
aussi mieux mieux mieux pour ses
étudiants avec effectivement 140000
boursiers qui vont changer d'échelons et
qui vont gagner entre bénéficier entre
66 euros et 127 euros par mois de plus
pour ces boursiers et au minimum
l'ensemble de tous les étudiants
boursiers pourront bénéficier de ces 37
euros qui correspond souvent à une
augmentation de 34% pour les plus petits
échelons et de 6% plus pour les plus
hauts échelons je voulais revenir sur
cette effectivement pérennisation de ce
repas à tarif très social que cette
majorité ce gouvernement a mis en place
ce repas un euro qui sera effectivement
pérennisé en plus du repas social à 3,30
€ qui est gelé pour la rentrée avec les
gels des loyers du CROUS parce que le
logement et la restauration sont aussi
des éléments très importants pour nos
étudiants alors je voulais insister que
tout ça était obtenu après une
concertation de plus de six mois avec
les représentants étudiants qui ont pu
justement reconnaître cette avancée pour
l'ensemble des étudiants et cette
concertation bien je vous l'annonce va
pouvoir continuer aussi bien au niveau
territorial que au niveau national sur
l'ensemble de la vie étudiante je
voudrais dire vous voyez nous agissons
ce gouvernement agit sur le pont les
étudiants et cette réforme des bourses
pour être mis au bénéfice de cette
majorité je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
je vous demanderai mes chers collègues
de faire un peu de silence il y a un
brouhaha constant qui gênent les
orateurs
[Musique]
vous avez la parole ma chère collègues
je demande le silence s'il vous plaît je
vous remercie de le respecter
la parole est à Madame Sandra rogol pour
le groupe écologiste
229%. c'est l'augmentation des
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire sur
les 10 dernières années en France soit
une multiplication par 3 du nombre des
bénéficiaires avec une augmentation
drastique ces deux dernières années
évidemment vous le savez bien les trois
quarts de ces bénéficiaires quasiment
sont des femmes toujours les premières
victimes et dans l'indifférence générale
j'en entends kerican à côté et de plus
en plus de travailleurs pauvres
d'étudiants de retraité c'est ce que me
rappelait hier encore la Banque
Alimentaire du bar en fait toutes les
personnes que vont réformes affectent
directement sur dans les supermarchés
les prix explosent autour de 17% et en
particulier ce désaillement premier prix
autour de 30% le cercle vicieux de
l'inflation ma son plein la pauvreté
explose et l'alimentation devient bien
évidemment le budget le budget
d'ajustement des ménages c'est un recul
terrible pourtant pour parler votre
langage mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la pauvreté coûte beaucoup
plus cher que les investissement
nécessaire à son éradication nous vous
proposons donc une chose faisons des
économies en agissant on évalue à 8 à 10
millions le nombre de personnes qui ne
peuvent plus manger assez ou alors ferme
en réponse Vous avez parlé de chèques de
panier certes le champ de lexical est là
l'action en revanche on l'attend
toujours la proposition de loi de ma
collègue Francesca parce que ni propose
justement une réponse d'urgence avec une
prime alimentation de 50 euros par mois
et par personne bien moins que ce que
nous aurions souhaité mais nous avons
cherché à la rendre acceptable même par
vos troupes elle propose aussi d'éviter
4000 cancers par an en supprimant les
nitrites et de prendre soin des enfants
et du climat en renforçant l'alternative
végétarienne dans les cantines des
investissements pour l'avenir donc
malheureusement vos troupes l'ont
réduite à une aide sèche de 2 euros 2
euros par an et par personne monsieur le
ministre ma question est donc pourquoi
votre gouvernement fait le choix de
mettre en danger sanitaire et
alimentaire
la population française je vous remercie
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs est
député madame la députée Sandra rogol
vous seriez un peu plus crédible dans
votre indignation si vous aviez voté les
mesures que nous avons adoptées pour le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages les plus
modestes
vous seriez un peu plus crédible vous et
toute la nupaisse et toute la France
insoumise si vous aviez voté la
revalorisation des aPL la revalorisation
des minima sociaux la révolisation des
bourses étudiantes dont vient de parler
Sylvie retaillod le repas 1 euro pour
les boursiers
vous seriez un peu plus crédible dans
votre indignation sur les travailleurs
si vous aviez voté l'indemnité carburant
pour les travailleurs pour ceux qui
travaillent pour ceux qui sont les plus
modestes
vous sauriez un peu plus crédible dans
votre indignation sur l'inflation si
vous aviez voté le bouclier qui protège
tous les ménages français contre
l'explosion des prix du gaz et
l'explosion des prix de l'électricité
vous seriez un peu plus crédible si au
lieu de faire preuve d'idiologies sur
les propositions que nous avons faites
pour protéger nos compatriotes vous
aviez soutenu les mesures du
gouvernement et de la première ministre
pour le pouvoir d'achat des plus
modestes vous seriez plus crédible dans
votre indignation pour les plus modestes
si vous et la France insoumise vous
n'aviez pas proposé de supprimer la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires des ouvriers des
employés des travailleurs les plus
modestes de ceux qui sont au niveau du
SMIC vous allez leur voler 150 euros par
mois en supprimant la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires vous seriez
un peu plus crédible vous et la France
insoumise dans votre indignation pour
les plus modestes pour les pour les
commerçants pour les artisans si vous
n'aviez pas voté et proposer
l'augmentation des cotisations chez
employeurs qui vont retirer 700 euros
par mois un fleuriste qui embauche un
salarié au niveau du SMIC voilà la
France insoumise des indignations de
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre merci
la parole
est à Monsieur Bruno Bill de pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
le coup des énergies et des carburants
est un niveau rarement atteint et
aujourd'hui ce sont les produits
courants qui ont vu leur prix augmenter
de manière insupportable le lait plus
10%, le beurre + 20 %, les pâtes plus
32%, les œufs plus 10% et dans le même
temps les vols à l'étalage explose mes
chers collègues quand on a de l'argent
on fait des choix mais quand on en a
plus on fait des sacrifices nos CCAS
n'ont jamais eu à traiter autant de
demandes d'aide et de secours jusqu'au
demande de prise en charge par des
municipalités des frais d'obsèques pour
éviter aux Français l'indigence alors
les Français rognent sur leur loisirs
sur les produits de première nécessité
mais surtout sur leur santé ils ne
peuvent plus payer leur mutuelle pendant
que les clandestins continuent de
bénéficier de l'aide médicale d'État
sans jamais avoir cotisé un centime
en disant en disant le nombre de pays
bénéficiaires des banques alimentaires a
été multipliée par 3 dont l'immense
partie sur les deux dernières années
plus 22% de fréquentation au restaurant
du coeur du jamais vu les paniers
entiers inflation encouragés par le
gouvernement ne sont que des outils
marketing en faveur de la seule grande
distribution et ont prouvé leur
inefficacité dans le même temps vous
refusez la taxation du super profit qui
permettrait d'aller chercher vos
recettes ailleurs que dans la poche des
Français et vous refusez notre
proposition d'une TVA à 0% sur 100
produits de première nécessité preuve
que vous ne resignez pas à faire des
cadeaux plus riches quand vous réservez
votre brutalité à d'autres brutalités de
votre réforme des retraites brutalité de
votre 49,3 indigne brutalité de votre
cas social brutalité dans votre raquette
fiscale madame la Première ministre
quand allez-vous entendre la souffrance
des Français
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie et des finances
[Applaudissements]
et je vois que Laura semble national à
la même indignation de façade que celle
de la nupes ça ne me surprend pas
mais là aussi monsieur bint vous seriez
un tout petit peu plus crédible dans
votre indignation de façade si vous
aviez voté le soutien aux travailleurs
si vous aviez voté l'indemnité carburant
travailleur de 100 euros pour ceux qui
vont travailler si vous aviez soutenu le
bouclier énergétique sur les factures de
gaz et sur les factures de l'électricité
qui ont protégé nos compatriotes contre
la flambée les prix de la criticité et
contre la flambée des prix du gaz la
récupération
démarre sur les grandes entreprises
énergétiques ça s'appelle la
contribution sur la rente infra
marginale elle rapporte plusieurs
milliards d'euros elle permet de
financer notre bouclier sur le gaz elle
permet de financer notre bouquet sur
l'électricité elle permet d'éviter des
augmentations de 180 à 200 euros des
factures par mois et Madame Le Pen
vous n'avez pas soutenu la contribution
sur la rente infra marginale vous ne
proposez aucune solution pour protéger
nos compatriotes contre la flambée des
prix quant au prix de l'alimentaire j'ai
demandé au distributeur de mettre en
place un trimestre anti inflation qui
est impliqué actuellement et dont nous
vérifierons la mise en œuvre j'ai envoyé
aujourd'hui la lettre qui demande au
distributeur et aux industriels de
rouvrir son délai les négociations
commerciales pour que les prix de gros
qui commencent à baisser commencent à se
répercuter sur les prix à la
consommation les indignations de façade
elles sont ici elles sont là les
réponses concrètes aux problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat des Français elles sont
dans la majorité
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie Agnès
poussié vincebak pour le groupe horizon
c'est un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre Hervé
Berville mes chers collègues je viens
d'un territoire qui a subi l'arrêt de la
Grand pêche dans les années 80 le
plongeant dans une crise profonde chaque
fait qu'en poids qu'il a vécu s'en
souvient comme si c'était hier la ville
a mis des décennies à se remettre de
cette décision canadienne de mettre en
place des quotas
mes chers collègues la pêche en
Normandie comme en Bretagne c'est une
boussole elle fixe le cap
fin de semaine dernière j'ai entendu les
pêcheurs de mon territoire j'ai lu aussi
les déclarations du président du Comité
national des pêches maritimes et des
élevages marins qui exprimaient toute la
colère d'une profession face à je le
cite une accumulation des normes des
menaces des contentieux qui remettent en
cause le fondement même de notre métier
en nous culpabilisant
c'est terrible d'entendre ça monsieur le
ministre ces professionnels ont choisi
ce métier difficile pour de nombreuses
raisons mais notamment pour nous nourrir
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin que nous
puissions leur redonner espoir ils ont
besoin que nous leur accordions notre
confiance
monsieur le ministre comment encourager
des jeunes à choisir ce métier ou à
reprendre des activités quand des
réglementations européennes totalement
inadaptées mettre le feu aux poudres
quand une décision du Conseil d'État est
incomprise quand vous avez le sentiment
que les contrôles sont toujours exercés
sur les mêmes et qu'ils ne s'applique
pas de la même manière sur ceux qui
pratiquent les techniques de pêche
industrielle
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
vous battez au quotidien aux côtés des
pêcheurs pourriez-vous faire un point
auprès de la représentation nationale
sur les actions que vous portez pour les
défendre et qui je l'espère redonneront
espoir à une profession et à des
territoires entiers merci je vous
remercie
de la mer
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
madame la députée Marie-Agnès poussié
windsback d'abord je voulais vous
remercier de votre engagement auprès des
pêcheurs de votre territoire pour
continuer à avoir cette filière qui fait
je crois la fierté de nos espaces
littoraux mais de manière plus générale
la fierté de notre pays et oui nous
pouvons nous devons être fiers du
travail des pêcheurs qui depuis des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années on
démontré que l'on pouvait allier et
concilier bon état écologique du milieu
marin et développement de la filière
halieutique et c'est un enjeu aussi de
souveraineté alimentaire puisque nous
dépendons déjà à plus de 80% pour les
importations de nos poissons et oui nous
devons continuer à les soutenir et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me suis rendu
avec une délégation de pêcheurs à la
Commission européenne dimanche pour
avoir la confirmation et bien que la non
reconnaissance des efforts qui étaient
et bien proposé par la Commission
européenne n'était pas acceptable ce que
vous le savez nous avons partout sur nos
littoraux des pêcheurs je pense à la
coquille je pense à la langoustine je
pense aux producteurs d'huîtres qui
démontre et bien que nous devons
continuer à avoir une activité de pêche
par tous les sur le territoire c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis rendu
aussi en Vendée auprès des pêcheurs pour
les écouter pour continuer à travailler
ou entendre les codes d'Armor alors nous
allons continuer à les soutenir à
travers notamment les carburants qui est
prolongé jusqu'à la fin de l'année c'est
plus de 85 millions d'euros nous allons
continuer à les soutenir en accélérant
la décarbonation et la transition
écologique du secteur avec 20 millions
d'euros cette année pour remotoriser
pour réduire la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et nous allons continuer et je
sais que vous avez un lycée maritime
dans votre territoire en investissant
fortement dans la formation dans les
lycées parce que nous avons besoin
d'avoir une pêche en France c'est un
enjeu de souveraineté alimentaire et
c'est un enjeu aussi d'être fidèle à
notre tradition et notre héritage en la
matière donc on continue et merci de
votre engagement merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à Madame Daniel obono pour
le groupe la France insoumise
rien n'y fera ni les 47 ans les 44,3 les
49,3 à répétition ni les arrestations et
garde à vue arbitraire pour étouffer la
constestation sous le regard à l'armée
et probatoire de toutes les institutions
nationales et internationales de défense
des droits humains et de l'état droit ni
les grossières tentatives de diversion
dans Pif têtu ou Playboy ni les fumeuses
consultations commendité par Emmanuel
Macron pour je cite bâtir un programme
de gouvernement et un programme
législatif 9 mois après être arrivé au
pouvoir aucun des groupes parlementaires
de la nups ne participera à cette
mascarade le rejet de votre réforme des
retraites reste massif 68% des Français
et des Françaises ils sont toujours
fermement opposés l'agitation populaire
persiste et signe partout dans le pays
les étudiants et étudiants de Nanterre
dauphines la Sorbonne Paris 8 Versailles
Cergy et Sciences Po en Île-de-France
mais aussi Lille peau Miss Poitiers
Toulouse Grenoble tours nouveau camp et
Nantes sont entrés en une les blocages
continuent hier c'était le périphérique
de Nantes ce matin 4 trames grenoblois
la base opérationnelle enedis d'Arcueil
et celle du site de Brive ceux de
l'usine de traitement des déchets d'ici
les Moulinaux et du centre technique de
Rezé sont toujours en cours malgré les
requisitions des grèves se reconduites
ou annoncées dans plusieurs secteurs le
dépôt pétrolier de Coignières est bloqué
les raffineries de Gonfreville-l'Orcher
la Vera est grave en champ for Jérôme
sont à l'arrêt après avis de grève
illimité des éboueurs parisiens a été
annoncé à partir du 13 avril gloire au
grévistes nous ne lâche rien il n'y aura
pas de trêve pas de suspension pas de
médiation à affirmer la toute nouvelle
secrétaire général de la CGT et ce jeudi
l'appel de l'insert syndical les
Français et les Françaises vous le
rappelleront dans la rue Madame la
première ministre vous voulez tourner la
page sortir le pays du chaos social et
démocratique dans lequel l'obstination
d'un président boukeris ait la plongée
dans le des mois la seule et su
raisonnable pacifique et démocratique
mais le retrait madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
présidente madame la députée au Bono
madame la députée vous vous posez comme
porte-parole des quatre groupes de
gauche de cette émission pour dire que
vous ne participerez à rien il n'y a
justement rien de nouveau dans votre
interpellation vous ne participez à rien
vous ne proposez rien vous dissimulez la
réalité c'est que vous dissimulez la
réalité de votre projet dites-le madame
bobonneau que vous voulez prendre de
l'argent aux Français qui gagne un peu
plus de 1500 euros par mois dites que
vous voulez prendre de l'argent aux
artisans au boulanger au boucher au
charcutier à tous ceux qui font vivre
nos quartiers en diminuant toutes les
exonérations dites que vous voulez
rendre l'emploi plus cher dites que vous
voulez du chômage dites que vous voulez
de la pauvreté votre projet madame la
députée c'est la ruine et c'est la
pauvrissement des Français et la seule
chose la seule chose que vous proposez
la seule chose que vous défendez c'est
une terrible inversion des valeurs vous
faites des policiers les responsables
alors ce sont les casseurs et
responsables vous souhaitez les blocages
vous souhaitez le désordre vous
souhaitez la Charlie vous souhaitez
délégitimer les institutions de la
République la seule chose que vous
voulez madame la députée c'est le
désordre et l'anarchie nous nous sommes
le cœur de la responsabilité et de la
raison et nous ne vous laisserons pas
faire
[Musique]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Emilie Bonivard
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la Santé
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence tel
est le cri que vous adresse tous les
professionnels des EHPAD et des services
de soins à domicile qui accompagnent les
personnes âgées tous les voyants sont au
rouge pénurie quasi généralisée de
personnels soignants des établissements
en déficit en raison de l'inflation
épuisement des professionnels qui
restent en poste les soignants sont
contraints par manque de temps
d'effectuer leur métier pourtant
profondément humain à la tâche et à la
chaîne 5 minutes pour un lavage de pieds
pas de temps pour plus d'une douche par
semaine 5 minutes pour la pose de basse
contention et pas une seconde de plus
pour un temps d'échange car il faut
passer au suivant
ce que nous faisons vivre tant à nos
aînés qu'aux professionnels qui les
accompagnent par manque de moyens est
inhumain c'est une forme de maltraitance
institutionnelle subie à quoi
servons-nous chers collègues ici dans
notre mandat si nous ne sommes pas
capables de mettre au coeur de nos
priorités le soin des plus fragiles de
nos aînés de leur permettre de vivre
dans la douceur la dignité et avec
humanité
nous examinons en ce moment une
proposition loi du groupe majoritaire
dénommé pour une société du Bien
vieillir mais Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues on va se dire la vérité on est
complètement à côté de la plaque on
attend décalage total avec les besoins
criants du terrain aucun des problèmes
majeurs qui conduisent à cette situation
intenable n'est traitée rien sur les
moyens budgétaires rien sur
l'attractivité réelle des métiers du
grand âge rien sur la formation alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple acant de vrais moyens et une
vraie réforme en faveur du grand âge il
y a
urgence
je vous remercie ma chère collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
délégué chargé du renouveau démocratique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
c'est mon collègue Jean-Christophe combe
qui aurait dû vous répondre mais il est
justement en train de conclure le
Conseil national de la refondation sur
le Bien vieillir et m'a confié cette
mission de vous répondre madame la
députée vous avez raison quand vous
dites que on est dans une situation de
grande détresse dans beaucoup
d'établissements du domaine
médico-social pour les personnes âgées
mais aussi pour les personnes non âgées
en situation de handicap il faut le dire
avec un vrai problème profond
d'attractivité des métiers que nous
avons pris à bras le corps avec la
question du Ségur qui a permis
d'augmenter les salaires mais qui ne
suffit pas à répondre à la détresse de
soignants qui se retrouve trop souvent
en sous nombre par rapport aux missions
qui leur incombe lorsque vous avez dans
un EHPAD sans résidant avec deux
personnes seulement la nuit pour
effectuer l'échange assurer les soins
etc on sait que ça participe de la
lassitude qui peut conduire aux
démissions et surtout aux difficultés de
recrutement madame la député le seul
point de désaccord que j'aurais avec
vous c'est quand vous dites qu'il y a
pas d'ambition budgétaire parce que ça
ne se sait peut-être pas suffisamment
mais entre 2021 et 2026 ce sont plus de
10 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
annuels consacré à l'accompagnement du
Bien Vieillir notamment dans le virage
homiciliaire mais également dans les
établissements médico-sociaux vous avez
voté madame la député dans le mandat
précédent la création de la cinquième
branche et avec cette création de 5e
branche il est prévu un mécanisme qui
fait qu'à compter de l'année prochaine
il y a une part de CSG à hauteur de 2
milliards et demi qui va venir abonder
également ses fonds pour pouvoir
financer davantage de dépenses de prise
en charge des personnes âgées en
établissement ou à domicile donc
l'ambition budgétaire elle est là et
d'ailleurs c'est assez rare que d'avoir
déterminé un budget avant de déterminer
dans la loi comment est-ce qu'on va le
dépenser alors vous avez quelques pistes
puisque nous avons annoncé la première
ministre l'a annoncé 50 000 recrutements
supplémentaires dans les cinq années sur
le secteur médico-social et notamment
pour les personnes âgées c'est un plan
de recrutement absolument massif mais ça
ne suffit pas c'est pourquoi il fallait
une proposition parlementaire de loi de
la majorité j'en salue les auteurs amis
Vidal Laurence cristal ainsi que Monique
ibora qui va permettre d'améliorer aussi
tout ce qui est gouvernance et prise en
charge dans la bienfait
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Pascal Boyer pour
le comprenait sens
merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre jeudi
30 mars le président de la République
est venu annoncer le plan d'eau le plan
haut pardon à sa ville le lac commune
symbolique pour annoncer ce plan car au
bout des années 60 l'ancien village de
sa ville a été recouvert par les eaux
pour la création du lac de Serre-Ponçon
retenue d'eau qui a permis les
traitements des crues de la Durance la
production d'hydroélectricité avec le
barrage l'irrigation agricole en aval de
la vallée et une activité touristique
attirant des centaines de milliers de
touristes chaque été dans le département
des Hautes-Alpes ce plan attendu fait
partie des priorités de la planification
écologique en apportant des réponses aux
enjeux environnementaux et économiques
l'année 2022 a été marquée par une
sécheresse qui a duré plusieurs mois et
qui a touché la quasi intégralité de
notre territoire
93 départements étaient soumis à des
restrictions d'eau et plus de 1000
communes ont connu des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en eau potable le
début de cette année a été marqué par
une sécheresse hivernale qui a duré 32
jours comment préparer rapidement l'été
2023 et éviter les coupures en eau
potable sécuriser l'approvisionnement en
eau potable de nos concitoyens et
diminuer les fuites dans les réseaux
comment informer nos concitoyens des
éco-gestes à adopter pour économiser 10%
d'eau dans tous les secteurs d'ici 2030
pour la production d'énergie pour
l'industrie de nos entreprises pour
l'agriculture pour les collectivités
territoriales pour les territoires
d'outre-mer et bien sûr pour les
particuliers à travers ce plan c'est une
véritable politique de l'eau qui se
mette en place pour organiser notre
sobriété pour optimiser la gestion de la
ressource pour préserver la qualité de
l'eau monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous dire comment les mesures annoncées
par le Président de la République la
semaine dernière vont nous permettre de
faire face aux sécheresses à venir et
d'améliorer considérablement la gestion
de la ressource en eau je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Pascal Boyer
demain nous publierons la mission
d'inspection qui établit le retour
d'expérience de la sécheresse que nous
avons connue l'été dernier vous l'avez
dit une sécheresse hors normes 93
départements avec des restrictions 75 en
crise plus de 700 communes privées d'eau
potable
depuis le mois de septembre ce sont 500
chantiers qui ont été lancés pour
sécuriser une partie de l'été qui arrive
depuis le mois de septembre dernier des
le 23 février avec Bérengère Couillard
nous avons réuni le comité
d'anticipation sécheresse réunit les
préfets fait en sorte de faire un point
mais plus largement au-delà de ces
mesures de préparation qui se
poursuivent et du point que nous ferons
en quelques jours a été présenté vous
l'avez dit par le Président de la
République il y a quelques jours le plan
o dont les fondations ont été posées
sous l'égide de la première ministre à
la fin du mois de septembre à Marseille
avec Bérengère Couillard avec Agnès
Firmin le Baudot et avec l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'eau dans ce pays dont Jean
leney que je veux saluer 53 mesures
c'est 53 mesures c'est compliqué de les
détailler devant vous en quelques
minutes mais je sais que j'aurai le
plaisir dans quelques jours devant la
DADT à invitation du Président Voulzy
d'entrer dans le détail pour me
contenter de quelques-unes d'abord
économiser l'eau
l'économiser en faisant en sorte d'avoir
des trajectoires de baisse de nos
prélèvements territoire par territoire
bassin par bassin avec des plans
d'adaptation au changement climatiques à
hauteur de 10% avant la fin de cette
année deuxièmement faire en sorte
d'optimiser la ressource lutter contre
les fuites 20% de fuites en moyenne sur
les réseaux d'eau potable dans notre
pays c'est évidemment beaucoup trop
réutiliser les eaux usées nous sommes à
moins d'un pour cent c'est un chantier
pour lequel nous devons suivre l'exemple
de nos voisins italiens espagnols
préparez la gouvernance donner des
moyens et faire en sorte de sensibiliser
nos concitoyens à travers une
application simple et géolocalisée voilà
les principales mesures la suite en
commission très bientôt
je vous remercie monsieur
la parole est à
Madame G
merci merci madame la Présidente malgré
vos incantations à passer à autre chose
les français eux ne tournent pas la page
ils sont dans leurs immenses majorité
chaque jour encore mobilisé pour vous
dire leur refus d'un recul de à 64 ans
de l'âge de départ à la retraite notre
groupe tient à dire toute son admiration
au travailleuse et travailleurs qui
poursuivent leur action de grève partout
sur le territoire malgré ce qui leur en
coûte au quotidien éboueur raffineur
docker agent de la RATP SNCF
enseignant soignant à tous nous leur
adressons notre soutien sans faille
notre groupe tient aussi à saluer la
jeunesse qui au côté des travailleurs et
des retraités expriment une autre vision
de la société notre groupe tient aussi à
assurer à nos concitoyens qui s'y aussi
nous ne lâchons rien c'est pourquoi ce
matin les parlementaires communistes et
ult et les députés du groupe IOT se sont
présentés devant l'Elysée afin
d'interpeller une fois encore le premier
responsable de cette situation de crise
sociale et démocratique Emmanuel Macron
nous lui avons remis un courrier dans
lequel nous lui rappelons que la
revendication des Français et de leur
représentant un droit juste et digne à
la retraite et pleinement légitime en
revanche ce qui est ce qui est
illégitime c'est cette réforme contre le
peuple qui n'a même pas fait l'objet
d'un examen parlementaire aboutit ni
même d'un vote ce qui est illégitime
c'est ce gouvernement qui méprise
l'expression si forte si déterminée de
nos concitoyens et d'un front syndical
historique par son unité le groupe GDR
attend désormais une seule réponse celle
du président de la République auquel
nous disons encore vous avez les moyens
et la responsabilité de la sortie de
crise renoncer à votre Funest e réforme
mais si vous rendez la parole au peuple
en la soumettant à un référendum merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier du soft ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la députée vous dites madame le député
n'attendent qu'une réponse celle du
président de la République vous imaginez
je ne parlerai pas à sa place par contre
je voudrais vous dire peut-être deux
choses la première c'est que nous dites
nous lâcherons rien et cette réforme
vous ne pouvez pas tourner la page je
vous le confirme et nous ne voulons pas
tourner la page demain avec madame la
Première ministre nous recevrons
l'interdy syndicale nous évoquerons tous
les sujets qu'il souhaite évoquer les
retraites mais aussi notre sujet autour
du travail il n'est pas question de
considérer que cette réforme une fois
votée serait oubliée qu'il serait effacé
ou qu'elle serait derrière elle fait
partie de notre histoire elle fait
partie désormais les acquis et sous
réserve bien évidemment de la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel nous aurons à
la mettre en oeuvre ne pas tourner la
page c'est aussi veiller toujours sous
réserve de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel que l'ensemble des
mesures puisse être mise en œuvre la
revalorisation des plus petites pensions
la mise en compte la prise en compte de
l'usure professionnelle le fait de
travailler pour l'emploi des seniors ce
sont ces chantiers et bien d'autres que
nous voulons découvrir et que nous
voulons continuer nous tendons donc pas
la page et nous souhaitons pouvoir
mettre en note cette réforme parce que
cette réforme est utile pour l'ensemble
des Français ne pouvant aussi nous
voulons aussi continuer à travailler
pour ouvrir un certain nombre de champs
autour de la gestion des carrières pour
renforcer les dispositions que nous
avons déjà intégré sur la question de
l'usure ou de l'emploi des seigneurs il
y a beaucoup à faire et nous espérons
que demain cette reprise du dialogue
permettra d'évoquer d'envisager qu'il y
ait des possibilités à nouveau de
convergence merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame Gisèle le Louis
pour le rassemblement national
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur hier la France s'est
réveillée sous le choc de voir qu'à
Marseille les fusillades empires empirés
sur fond de trafic de drogue trois morts
12 blessés durant la triple fusillade de
ce weekend soit 14 tués par armes à feu
et 43 blessés en trois mois je veux
saluer tout d'abord avec le groupe
rassemblement national le courage et le
travail formidable des services de
secours et de sécurité submergé en
France et notamment à Marseille mais
comment ne peut-on pas être triste et en
colère lorsque certains prétendent
lutter contre le trafic de drogue
internationale tout en installant des
salles de shoot le renforcement de notre
action diplomatique de la douane de la
police de la justice et de la prévention
médicale sont urgents chez nous certains
consomment de la drogue comme si c'était
des bonbons or consommer donne une
responsabilité comment se fait-il que
seul 30% des consommateurs verbalisés
payent leurs amendes comment
responsabiliser vous les parents donc
ils empêchent leurs gamins d'aller
shooter chauffer pardon pour 1000 euros
par jour à la paternelle les gens ont
peur de se prendre une balle moi-même
j'ai connu cette peur alors vous envoyez
la crs8 ils vont rester trois jours
comme en février puis repartir et rien
ne changera vous me répondez que trois
unités de ce serait ont été déployés en
mars je discutais avec certains d'entre
eux il reste trois heures sur l'un des
130 points de l'île de la ville puis il
repartent sur ordre frustré et le trafic
reprend vous nous direz aussi que depuis
janvier 500 interpellations ont eu lieu
en lien avec le trafic combien ont été
relâchés que fait la justice voilà deux
ans et demi que vous êtes ministre avec
Monsieur Moretti qui avait vous fait
alors on le sait vous espériez beaucoup
ça devait bien se passer mais voilà la
poussière mise sous le tapis remonte à
la figure
voilà c'est votre bilan celui d'Emmanuel
Macron monsieur le ministre quelle
plante de bataille pour sauver Marseille
sur le trafic de drogue allez vous
laisser à votre successeur merci
beaucoup la parole à Éric Dupont-Moretti
gare de vaisseau ministre de la Justice
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée le Louis il y a une constance
que je vous reconnais que je reconnais
votre partie vous ne loupez jamais un
rendez-vous cynique avec le malheur et
pendant ce temps-là voyez-vous le
ministre de l'Intérieur est moi-même
nous agissons et nous avons mis en place
un plan Marshall à Marseille voilà
comment il se décline en 2022 20
magistrats nouveau sont arrivés
10 nouveaux greffiers en 2023 6
magistrats supplémentaires en deux ans
60 contractuels en matière de force de
sécurité intérieure c'est 300 policiers
qui sont arrivés et savez-vous madame la
députée comment on les a embauchés on
les a embauchés grâce au budget 2021 que
vous n'avez pas voté grâce au budget
2022 que vous n'avez pas voté grâce au
budget 2023 que vous n'avez pas voté
alors je voudrais enfin vous dire que
vous n'êtes pas commentateur vous êtes
acteur de la vie politique dans les
niches RN que proposez-vous pour la
justice 0 en réalité en réalité madame
la députée vous nous opposez le silence
et la critique votre programme je vais
vous dire ce que c'est un cimetière de
certitude et vous êtes orphelins du
réalisme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
pour le groupe démocrate
merci Benoîte ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé de
transport monsieur le ministre le
secteur aéronautique est l'une des plus
grandes fiertés industrielles de notre
pays nous sommes aujourd'hui une des
seuls nations capables de construire un
avion de A à Z grâce aux 4000
entreprises de cette filière
aéronautique et au 263 000 emplois
directs au total c'est plus de 100
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
générés par ce secteur cependant si
notre devoir est de faire prospérer
cette belle industrie il est aussi de
notre responsabilité de prendre soin de
notre planète les connaissances et les
consciences évoluent et nos concitoyens
ont beaucoup d'attentes sur la
transition de ce secteur les Français
continuent à regarder le ciel avec Eva
émerveillement 8 sur 10 ont une très
bonne image des transports aériens mais
pour continuer à faire rêver l'avion
doit se décarboner
les acteurs du secteur ont déjà pris la
mesure de ce défi en témoigne les
engagements de l'accord de Toulouse
signé en 2022 pour un secteur neutre en
carbone à l'horizon 2050
outre l'avion hydrogène développé en
Haute-Garonne par un effort conjoint
inédit les acteurs publics et privés le
développement des safs c'est
biocarburant quasiment neutre en CO2 est
une condition indispensable au
verdissement et à l'avenir du secteur à
ce titre le projet de règlement européen
en cours de discussion porte une
ambition forte d'intégration progressive
de ces carburants monsieur le ministre à
l'heure où certains d'entre nous
privilégie systématiquement
l'interdiction à la recherche de
solutions notre rôle est d'accompagner
avec vigueur cette transition en
défendant ce projet ambitieux à
l'échelle européenne et pesée de toutes
nos forces en fait de rehausser ses
objectifs aussi pouvez-vous nous
confirmer l'attachement du Gouvernement
au développement de ces biocarburants
français conditions indispensables à
notre souveraineté onautique plus
généralement quel sera votre méthode
pour porter notre voix au niveau
européen et pour s'assurer du soutien de
cette industrie capital pour notre pays
je vous remercie je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre chargé des
transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
skinnégox vous avez raison nous avons
une industrie d'excellence qui est
l'aéronautique qui est industrie une
industrie d'innovation l'industrie
d'exportation l'industrie créatrice
d'emploi vous avez aussi raison de
souligner qu'il n'y a aucun avenir pour
l'aviation au cannavenir pour l'avion
sans décarbonation cette stratégie nous
l'apportons avec beaucoup de
détermination au niveau français
européen et même international nous
avons fixé en effet il y a un an sous
président français de l'Union européenne
avec tous nos partenaires de l'Union
européenne et au-delà un objectif qui
nous engage de décarbonation totale de
ce secteur d'ici 2050 c'est-à-dire en
moins d'une génération cet objectif j'ai
eu l'occasion de le porter à Montréal au
niveau international il engage
maintenant plus de 180 pays dans le
monde et nous sommes donc engagés sur le
plan écologique sur le plan industriel
sur le plan économique dans cette
immense transformation qui est un
nouveau chapitre de l'aviation après des
révolutions que nous avons connues
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle nous
réussirons cet objectif grâce au
savoir-faire qui est unique au monde
nous sommes peut-être avec les
États-Unis d'Amérique le seul pays
réussi à savoir en effet produire un
avion de A à Z la moitié de cette
stratégie de décarbonation c'est
l'innovation dans les carburants
durables on le sait aujourd'hui la
France a été pionnière la matière
puisque votre assemblée a voté il y a
quelques mois le fait que nous ayons une
incorporation obligatoire de cette
carburant dans nos avions et nous avons
en ce moment un règlement européen pour
répondre très simplement que nous
soutenons très activement qui sera
adopté dans les prochaines semaines et
qui sera le premier règlement au monde
pour 450 millions d'habitants à fixer un
objectif en 2030 d'incorporation massive
de ces carburants dans tous nos avions
avec le ministre de l'Industrie Roland
Lescure avec la mise de l'énergie Agnès
panière unachier nous avons nous avons
réuni l'ensemble des industriels des
énergéticiens pour créer une filière
française de ces carburants durables
nous aurons en d'ici le Bourget le salon
Coulommiers inaugurera le printemps de
la République l'occasion de présenter
une feuille de route pour produire ses
carburants durables en France et en
Europe c'est un enjeu écologique c'est
aussi un enjeu de souveraineté nous
pouvons développer cette filière il
faudra investir comme nous le faisons
dans le cadre du Plan France 2030
la parole est à Monsieur
Tommy
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur nous
avons découvert que vous nous accusiez
d'être complice d'un terrorisme
intellectuel nous avons naïvement pensé
qu'il s'agissait d'un poisson d'avril
avec certains fonds de vérité tout
travail intellectuel semblant en effet
vous terrorisez mais pendant que vous
étiez occupé à recycler les théories de
l'extrême droite pour servir vos
ambitions personnelles un compte Twitter
a révélé publiquement l'existence de
boucles télégramme néo-nazi invitant à
commettre des attentats contre nos
compatriotes musulmans et je vous parle
là d'un terrorisme bien concret et il a
fallu que ces tweets sortent pour vous
forcer à réagir de la plus faible des
manières puisque vous avez demandé à
télégramme de simplement fermer ces
canaux de discussion il y avait pourtant
dans ses boucles des membres actifs qui
étaient fonctionnaires aux militaires
l'État ne peut avoir qu'une seule
réponse envers eux dehors mais hier
lors d'un débat parlementaire sur le
terrorisme d'extrême droite proposé par
la nupes dans lequel vous n'êtes même
pas intervenu dans lequel la majorité
parlementaire n'a pas parlé une seule
seconde dans lequel vous avez catapulté
le ministre des Outre-mer témoignant de
votre extrême indigent sur le sujet
l'État a répondu qu'il n'avait pas
condamné des gens qui exprimaient
simplement une opinion pensez-vous
vraiment monsieur Darmanin qu'être
militaire et arboré des signes nazis par
exemple ce n'est que témoigner une
opinion monsieur Darmanin que vous
fassiez de la politique de la pire des
manières c'est une chose mais vous
n'avez pas le droit de vous affranchir
de vos responsabilités vous n'avez pas
le droit de vider les mots de leur sens
pour disqualifier vos adversaires pour
dissoudre des associations écologistes
quand le terrorisme d'extrême droite se
structure sous vos yeux vous n'avez pas
le droit d'instrumentaliser la laïcité à
des fins politiques et j'en profite pour
demander comme France 2 et les Samuel
patinon fait et sa famille ce qu'il est
advenu des millions d'euros dépensés par
le ministère de l'Intérieur dans le fond
Marianne une mosquée à Wattignies a été
saccagée infidèle à Échirolles a été
agressé les musulmans habitants à
Wazemmes ont été désignés pour cible en
plein ramadan vous savez que nous sommes
dans une période à risque pour nos
compatriotes musulmans comme nos
compatriotes chrétiens et juifs en
festivités monsieur Darmanin vous vous
égaré avant de faire votre campagne vous
devez faire votre travail merci
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Guiraud d'abord je vous demanderai
d'avoir plus de respect pour les membres
du gouvernement et régulièrement pour
Monsieur Jean-François caraco on choisit
pas les personnes qui posent des
questions permettaient au gouvernement
de choisir des ministres qui vous
répondent et Monsieur caraco mérite
comme chacun ici d'avoir un miam de
respect malheureusement ce mot n'est pas
simplement de gauche et votre
comportement
deuxièmement monsieur le député le prix
apisme avec lequel vous vous évoquez
sans doute mon action vous fait
malheureusement louper la vérité ce
groupe télégram était suivi par les
services de renseignement ce qui nous a
permis ce qui nous a permis monsieur le
député de pouvoir identifier les
personnes les 2300 abonnés de ce groupe
télégram qui indépendamment d’être fermé
est aujourd'hui judiciarisé pour être
identifié à notre connaissance il n'y a
d'ailleurs pas demande de la police
nationale dans ce groupe telegram ce que
vous évoquez très largement aucune
preuve de le montre et au moment où je
parle le parquet se réunit avec la
police judiciaires pour connaître le
service enquêteur qui permettra
justement de pouvoir non seulement
confondre ces personnes et les faire
condamner voyez monsieur le député
plutôt que de crier plutôt que parfois
de s'exciter il suffit parfois de
travailler mais il est vrai que les
services de renseignement ont besoin
parfois de confidentialité et de secret
qui ne le partagent pas avec en effet
l'actualité politique tous les jours
je n'ai aucune leçon ressort monsieur le
député de votre part d'abord dans le
lien avec les extrêmes oui l'ultra
gauche et l'ultra droite sont les deux
facettes d'extrémisme qui touche la
société française
je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir ces ce
gouvernement qui a dit sous notamment
généraliste identitaires et de
nombreuses milices d'extrême droite et
quand le lien entre l'islamisme et la
vie politique vraiment venant de vous ça
montre pas de sel je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Patrick Hetzel
pour le groupe les républicains
merci beaucoup madame la ministre ma
président pardon ma question s'adresse à
Madame la mise de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche madame la
ministre il y a quelques mois la
présidence de l'université Montaigne de
Bordeaux a interdit de parole madame
Sylviane againski philosophe en
considérant qu'il y avait un risque de
troubles à l'ordre public la semaine
dernière la même président de
l'université a laissé s'exprimer en son
sein Monsieur Jean-Marc Rouillon ce
dernier a pourtant été condamné pour
apologie du terrorisme mais emprisonné
pour deux assassinats caractères
terroristes à titre d'illustration dans
une interview il déclare au sujet des
frères Kouachi j'en ai marre des pensifs
antiterroriste moi je les ai trouvés
très courageux tout ceci est très
choquant je n'ose imaginer madame la
ministre que vous combattiez la
philosophie mais que vous protégiez le
terrorisme madame la ministre vous
assurez la tutelle des universités et
votre mission et de garantir le contrôle
de la légalité des universités
françaises étrangement on ne vous a
absolument pas entendu sur ce sujet ma
question est donc double pourquoi ce
silence assourdissant madame la ministre
et par ailleurs que comptez-vous faire
pour combattre une telle inversion des
valeurs parfaitement inacceptables au
sein de notre université française je
vous remercie je vous remercie mon cher
la gamme la parole est à Madame
Sylvie Retailleau ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Madame les députés monsieur le député
etzelle alors comme vous le savez et
vous l'avez dit vous êtes bien placé
pour le savoir historiquement il y a
l'autonomie des universités ce qui ne
permet pas tout et pendant
qu'effectivement on ne s'exprime pas on
travaille on travaille pour
effectivement garder le calme évitez les
blocus dans les universités et permettre
à ces universités cette liberté
académique en même temps que cette
expression tout en gardant le droit le
droit aux étudiants d'aller étudier le
droit au personnel d'aller accéder ces
universités monsieur le député c'est un
travail quotidien c'est un travail
quotidien que nous menons pour nos
étudiants et comme il me semble que tout
cela vous intéresse et bien ce travail
quotidien je réfère à ce que nous venons
de faire sur les bourses les annonces
récentes sur nos étudiants les annonces
récentes par rapport à tout ce qui est
lié
je vous remercie je remercie madame la
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues monsieur Hetzel
allez-y madame la ministre votre réponse
est incroyable est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte que du coup vous êtes dans
une situation où la même université
interdit Malga magasin ski et ça
personne ne trouve à dire c'est tout de
même inquiétant et de l'autre côté
l'apologie du terrorisme ne semble pas
vous déranger vous êtes ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche vous devez assurer la légalité
de tout cela la liberté académique doit
effectivement être défendue mais la
liberté académique doit aussi faire en
sorte que l'on respecte évidemment ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de cette
université vous-même vous avez pu
constater que trois jours après
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et bien une
dégradation massive cette université va
être fermée pendant plusieurs mois merci
la parole est à Monsieur
Hervé de l'épineau pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre le Salon de
l'Agriculture a été le cadre
traditionnel pour se faire photographier
au cul des vaches mais pas que cette
édition 2023 était aussi l'occasion
d'être les réceptacles des doléances
inquiétudes des professionnels des
filières présentes sur le salon à cet
égard la Fédération des vignerons
indépendants nous alerter sur les
difficultés rencontrées par une majorité
de ces adhérents pour rembourser les
prêts garantis par l'État dans les
délais impartis l'activité viticole
pendant la période covid n'a pu se
mettre en sommeil dans l'attente de
jours meilleurs puisque le cycle
végétatif nécessité les mêmes travaux de
conduite de la vigne quand par ailleurs
la commercialisation des stocks a subi
un coup d'arrêt du fait des confinements
successifs les PGE ont alors été mis en
place dans le but d'accompagner les
entreprises pour éviter qu'elles ne se
retrouvent en état de cessation des
paiements
aujourd'hui il faut rembourser ses
presses qui est tout à fait normal une
demande d'allongement du délai à 10 ans
a été formulé par de nombreux
professionnels et rejetés par Bercy au
motif qu'une durée de remboursement de
cette importance ne serait pas conforme
au droit européen en matière d'être
direct aux entreprises puisque Bruxelles
nous permet pas d'être souverain dans la
mise en œuvre de mécanismes de soutien
l'engagement de l'État devient une
condition de survie pour beaucoup
d'exploitation dans ces conditions et de
manière générale il est demandé de
substituer au PGE des prêts bonifiés par
l'État pour permettre l'allongement de
la durée de remboursement de manière
acceptable pour la trésorerie des
entreprises aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous prendre l'engagement d'une
mise en oeuvre rapide de ce mécanisme de
substitution son coût pour les finances
publiques étant bien moindre que les
pertes fiscales qu'occasionneraient des
dépôts de bilan d'entreprises je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la balance
la présidente et messieurs les députés
je pense que vous reconnaîtrez monsieur
le député l'épido que pendant toute la
crise du covid nous avons accompagné
soutenu protéger des entreprises que ce
soit dans la viticulture ou ailleurs
vous reconnaîtrez même si votre
Président nous fait le reproche d'avoir
trop dépensé pour protéger les
entreprises nous avons pris en charge
l'activité partielle le report de charge
et ses fameux prêts garantis par l'État
je vous confirme que nous n'avons laissé
tomber aucune entreprise pendant la
crise du covid et que nous ne laisserons
tomber aucune entreprise après la crise
du covid n'ont pas sauvé les entreprises
en 2020 et 2021 pour laisser tomber en
2022 et 2023 c'est pour ça que toute
entreprise qui rencontre des difficultés
financières particulières qu'elles
soient dans la vie culture ou ailleurs
peut aller demander auprès du médiateur
du crédit l'allongement de la durée de
son PGE de 6 ans à 10 ans comme vous le
souhaitez et comme nous l'avons mis en
place depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
quant à demander à l'État de prendre la
charge de ces prêts garanties là pour le
coup ce serait creusé les déficits
creuser la dette vous conviendrez avec
moi ça n'est pas la solution la plus
appropriée je merci Monsieur le minier
ministre monsieur de l'épineau oui
monsieur ministre j'exprime ma déception
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
10 ans de délai de remboursement de PGE
ça n'est pas possible après bonifier par
l'État c'est une garantie des tocs et je
rappelle que le coût de la mesure sera
beaucoup moins importantes que les
pertes fiscales qu'occasionneront les
dépôts de bilan
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis euh
non Lionel Royer Perrot pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer monsieur le
ministre Marseille souffre Marseille
pleure Marseille est en colère dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi pas moins de 3
règlements de comptes ont eu lieu
entraînant la mort de trois personnes
dont un adolescent de 16 ans et
l'hospitalisation de huit autres nous
constatons depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant une accélération de ces
assassinats sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiants une double logique de
contrôle territorial d'une part et de
vendetta d'autre part en serait à
l'origine cette situation mes chers
collègues est inquiétante car elle
intervient alors que Marseille connaît
une augmentation sensible de ses moyens
de police et de justice 300 policiers
nouveaux trois compagnies de CRS 30
magistrats dit greffiers tous en poste
au moment même où nous nous parlons et
ce grâce à la religion du président de
la République le travail réalisé à titre
d'illustrations de permis de démanteler
définitivement 39 points de deal de
saisir 5,4 tonnes de cannabis ou encore
de dresser
18600 oui vous avez bien entendu mes
chers collègues
18600 amants de forfaitaire délictuel
pour usage de stupéfiants pour autant
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
ne pas accepter cette résignation qui
semble s'abattre sur la ville et plonger
des familles entières dans la terreur et
la douleur pour soutenir la stratégie de
pilonnage menée par la préfète de police
nous devons me semble-t-il renforcer les
moyens de la direction zonale de la
police judiciaire et
occupé plus encore les quartiers par le
renforcement de la présence de CRS alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quels sont les moyens précis que
vous comptez allouer à Marseille de
façon pérenne pour mieux lutter contre
cette situation dramatique je vous en
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Royer Pérou je crois que Monsieur le
garder sur tout à l'heure a évoqué les
moyens de la justice mobiliser très
fortement à Marseille en complément des
moyens de la police nationale décidé
comme vous l'avez dit par le Président
de la République et qui n'ont pas
l'équivalent ni pour la cité phocéenne
ni pour aucun territoire de la
République 300 policiers de plus en deux
ans c'est effectivement du jamais vu et
nous continuerons cette progression je
veux dire en effet que c'est parce que
nous mettons énormément de moyens et
parce que les résultats vous avez cité
semaine dernière monsieur le député mais
ce depuis le 1er janvier c'est 509
individus interpellés pour trafic de
drogue une tonne 2 de cannabis saisie en
moins de 3 mois à Marseille et 48 kg de
cocaïne et 343 armes saisies ça vous
montre à la fois l'hyperactivité des
services mais également sans doute la
mer qu'il reste à vider dans certains
quartiers de conseil mais aussi dans
l'arrière-pays marseillais et donc j'ai
décidé d'abord pour mettre fin au
Vendetta aux guerres de territoire
puisque la procureur de la République
s'est exprimée et évoquait le fait que
nous avons des craintes pour les jours
pour les semaines qui viennent pour la
conquête de ces territoires de gens qui
sont sans doute d'ailleurs en prison ou
qui sont mis hors d'état de murs par les
services de police la CRS suite et comme
vous me l'avez demandé j'ai renforcé en
tout cas pour le mois de septembre
prochain les services d'enquêtes de la
police judiciaire à Marseille et la
création d'un nouveau groupe d'appui
d'enquêtes spécialisées de la police
judiciaire à Marseille qui fait un
travail très important je veux aussi
dire que vous savez à Marseille la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue une lutte qui
est très ancienne et malheureusement
internationale la maîtrise du port de
Marseille est un sujet extrêmement
important pour nous tous le lien qu'il y
a entre les trafiquants qui commandent
les assassinats ciblés et leur présence
à l'extérieur de notre territoire on
pense évidemment à des pays du Maghreb
ou à des pays du Moyen-Orient est
extrêmement importante l'été dernier
nous avons réussi avec le ministre de la
Justice avoir de meilleures coopération
pour obtenir les extraditions il y a
encore beaucoup de
grands cahiers de pardon en dehors de
notre sol nationale et nous y
travaillons pour pour qu'ils puissent
être traduit dans la justice et condamné
à de longues prison merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout pour le
groupe
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé monsieur le
ministre depuis hier la loir-riste
instaure le plafonnement des salaires
pour les médecins intérimaires cette loi
trouve une certaine légitimité en
faisant en sorte d'éviter les abus de
rémunération je crois qu'il faut en
convenir pour autant elle n'est pas sans
conséquence et accroît les difficultés
pour nos hôpitaux de proximité déjà
confrontés à une pénurie de soignants
dans l'Aisne mon département à Hirson à
Saint-Quentin mais aussi à fourmis à
Vitry de François Bastia à Auch à Shiva
partout la tension s'accélère dans les
services dans les urgences en anesthésie
en pédiatrie dans les services de soins
de suite et réadaptation et j'en passe
monsieur le ministre comme lors du covid
des interventions chirurgicales sont
toujours dit des programmés des leads
médecine de SSR même pudiquement gelées
pour pas dire fermer monsieur le
ministre vous tentez d'atténuer les
effets pervers de cette loi en portant
la garde de 24 heures à 1390 euros ou en
abondant les contrats par des contrats
de qu'on appelle de motifs 2 ou en
accordant une prime de solidarité
territoriale mais là n'est pas l'urgence
votre disposition ne répond pas aux
problèmes de fond celui des déserts
médicaux ni aux problèmes de
reconnaissance par la rémunération de
nos médecins au final si votre
disposition est nécessaire elle doit
être accompagnée de solutions durables
car une seule chose compte c'est la
détresse des patients sur nos
territoires quand allez -vous engager de
nouvelles concertations pour vous
attaquer au vrai problème et quels sont
vos propositions pérennes merci merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Brico je vous remercie de reconnaître la
validité et la mise en application par
ce gouvernement d'une loi votée dans
cette émission en 2016 d'une seconde loi
voté dans cette hémicycle en 2021 je
pourrais dire qu'il était temps de la
mettre en application alors de quoi
parle-t-on bien sûr pas de l'intérim
médical dans son ensemble mais d'une
dérive de cette intérim médical qui
s'apparente à un mercenariat qui font
que les gens font monter les prix et les
hôpitaux qui sont les plus touchés par
cette dérive sont justement les petits
hôpitaux qui sont pris en otage par ces
pratiques totalement contraire à
l'éthique l'éthique il faut la retrouver
si l'on veut reconstruire notre système
de santé sur des bases solides alors
lutter contre cette intérim mercenaire
mais aussi mais aussi favoriser nos
professionnels de santé qui sont dans
les hôpitaux qui tiennent la ligne
pendant le covid qui tiennent encore la
ligne qui sont plus fortement
sollicitées
pour cela j'ai rencontré déjà les
organisations syndicales seront revues
cette semaine nous avons prévu de nous
revoir encore la semaine prochaine pour
améliorer les conditions de travail de
ces professionnels vous dites que
partout il y a des difficultés partout
il y a des difficultés mais aujourd'hui
je peux dire que partout il y a des
solutions qui ont été trouvées grâce
comme dans votre département par
l'engagement territorial de l'hôpital de
Saint-Quentin voire même là aussi dans
votre département au niveau des urgences
d'Hirson qui sont en difficulté mais pas
depuis hier qui sont en difficulté
depuis plusieurs mois avec l'aide de
l'hôpital de Fourmies qui est distant de
12 km alors oui il faut régler cette
situation il faut assainir notre système
de santé cela en fait partie et
parallèlement nous commençons à
construire nous continuons à construire
des bonnes conditions de travail pour
les praticiens à l'hôpital parce que mon
objectif est de garder les bons et de
faire revenir ceux qui sont partis
merci
beau ministre monsieur Bricout merci
Monsieur le Ministre d'abord de votre
réponse encore une fois je crois que
c'est la santé nos concitoyens avant
tout engagez-vous donc dans de encore de
nouvelles concertations des propositions
transpartizanes pour la régulation sont
sur la table autorisées les débats et je
vous ai proposé aussi l'expérimentation
d'école normale de la santé pour
répondre aux besoins de territoires
autoriser cette expérimentation merci
beaucoup mon cher la parole est à Madame
Caroline Fiat pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci
madame monsieur le ministre de la Santé
tout ça pour ça une obstruction
gouvernementale sur une proposition de
loi du jamais vu sous la Cinquième
République pour aujourd'hui nous trouver
une nouvelle excuse les modalités
pourtant depuis la suspension il n'y a
eu aucune modalité particulière quand
celle et ceux qui avaient attrapé le
virus retourner travailler car ils
étaient considérés comme immunisés vous
avez sans cesse répété que la date
butoir serait la vie de la Haute
Autorité de Santé or cette autorité a
rendu un avis positif pour leur
réintégration le 30 mars dernier depuis
plus rien la loi du 30 juillet 2022
dispose bien que lorsqu'on regarde
l'évolution de la situation épidermique
telle que constatée par la Haute
Autorité de Santé l'obligation
vacciniale n'est plus justifiée celle-ci
est suspendue par décret il n'est pas
question de concertation quelconque
alors monsieur le ministre de quel
modalité parlez-vous devez-vous vérifier
que ces personnels ne seraient pas en
surectif
et vous vérifiez la disponibilité des
postes leur budgétisation peut être vous
savez aussi bien que moi que ce n'est
pas le cas dans tous les établissements
nous avons cruellement besoin d'eux vous
savez pertinemment qu'ils sont toutes et
tous prêts à reprendre le travail dans
l'heure après la décision scientifique
la question relève désormais uniquement
de votre prise de position politique
qu'attendez-vous
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
merci Anna la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la députée
Caroline Fiat pas vous vous pouvez pas
en tant que soignante mélangez la
situation épidémiologique d'il y a
plusieurs mois de la situation
épidémiologique d'aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que dans son
avis la Haute Autorité de Santé
reconnaît que la vaccination pendant la
crise a sauvé des vies et je voudrais
quand même entendre encore une fois dans
cette hémicycle le remerciement des
représentants de la nation envers ses
professionnels de santé qui se sont fait
vacciner et qui ont tenu la ligne et qui
ont sauvé des vies
concernant la vie pris par la Haute
Autorité de santé il s'agit d'un avis
sur les obligations vaccinales des
professionnels de santé n'ont pas un
avis sur la réintégration mais bien sur
les obligations maximales elles touchent
le covid elle touche la diphtérie elle
touche le tétanos elle touche la
poliomyélite elle touche l'hépatite B
qui heureusement est maintenue cet avis
est assorti de commentaires extrêmement
divers de la part des professionnels et
de beaucoup de critiques pour autant et
vous l'avez dit la loi comme on
engagement ici même dans cette hémicycle
c'est de suivre la vie de la Haute
Autorité de santé c'est obligation
vaccinale contre le covid et donc levé
maintenant il faut travailler à la
réintégration des soignants je souhaite
travailler à cette réintégration le
mieux possible pour qu'il soit accueilli
dans des services qui ne les rejettent
pas parce que vous savez comme moi que
beaucoup de professionnels de santé sont
opposés à leur retour je ne veux pas
créer un nouvel crise c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit que je réunissais dans les
jours qui viennent les ordres
professionnels les organisations
syndicales et des fédérations pour que
ce réintégration se passe le mieux
possible
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Fiat alors monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie pour vous remerciement
parce qu'effectivement soignante pendant
la crise j'ai été vaccinée dès janvier
2021 et je sais pertinemment que des
soignants parce qu'ils avaient attrapé
la covid dit immunisé sont déjà
retournés dans la services pour lesquels
vous n'aviez rien prévu pas de modalité
ni rien pourquoi faudrait-il une
modalité aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre de la santé c'est totalement
incohérent ces personnes n'ont pas eu de
salaire pendant plusieurs mois vous les
avez suspendus maintenant réintégrer les
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Charles
Larsonneur pour le groupe horizon merci
Madame le présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Agnès panier renacher
ministre de la transition énergétique
notre pays fait face à un défi immense à
l'horizon 2040 2050 garantir à nos
enfants une énergie en quantité
suffisante et un prix abordable face à
la raréfaction et au renchérisement
inéluctable des énergies fossiles c'est
la préservation de notre modèle
démocratique économique et sociale qui
est en jeu il revient donc à notre
génération de mener à bien une
passionnante aventure industrielle et
humaine sur le temps long
les discours du président de la
République au Creusot à Belfort puis les
deux lois successivement votés dans
cette hémicycle sous votre impulsion
avec des majorités de nets sur
l'accélération des énergies de
renouvelable d'une part et du nucléaire
d'autres parts ont posé déjà long
important je veux ici rendre hommage aux
femmes et aux hommes engagées dans cette
grande aventure industrielle soudeur
tuyauteur chaudronnier que nos
entreprises se disputent chèrement dans
tous les bassins d'emploi de Brest à
Saint-Nazaire comme ailleurs dans les
années à venir nous devons répondre
simultanément à la montée en puissance
du nucléaire le PR2 petit réacteur
modulaire de la filière éolienne
hydrolienne une croissance vigoureuse de
la construction navale et de l'industrie
métallurgique en général
nous risquons de manquer de cerveau et
de bras les entreprises filières et
groupements font leur part grâce à
l'apprentissage et la formation interne
les collectivités territoriales les
chambres consulaires les accompagnent
les réformes de l'apprentissage du lycée
professionnel contribuent à faire bouger
les lignes peut-être manquons-nous
encore de nouvelles écoles techniques
comment abordez-vous ce défi fondamental
de l'attractivité de la formation et du
maintien des compétences dans les
filières nucléaires navales et de la
métallurgie je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame ma nièce panier renacher le
ministre de la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
l'arseneur vous l'avez dit notre
politique énergétique vise à faire de la
France le premier grand pays à sortir
des énergies fossiles et pour cela nous
avons une ambition celle notamment de
relancer la filière nucléaire et
relancer la filière nucléaire c'est
relancer une des plus grandes aventures
industrielle qui a connu notre pays
depuis les années 70 c'est un projet
humain et industriel exceptionnel et
c'est un projet qui va nécessiter
énormément de compétences sur la seule
année 2023 nous allons devoir recruter
plus de 10
000 talents 10 000 talents dans tous les
niveaux de formation du bac
professionnel jusqu'au poste doctorance
ce sont des chaudronniers des tuyauteurs
des soudeurs des électrotechniciens
évidemment des ingénieurs et des
chercheurs que nous devons convaincre de
venir dans ces filières alors
vous avez raison de de le souligner nous
avons envoyé un signal très positif sur
les rangs de cette assemblée à la
filière nucléaire pour leur indiquer
notre investissement et je vais vous en
remercier maintenant nous agissons j'ai
l'ambition de lancer un plan Marshall
des compétences dans la filière
nucléaire nous y travaillons avec le
gifen vous savez c'est la réunion de
l'ensemble des industriels il me
remettront dans les prochains jours leur
évaluation de leurs besoins de
compétences plus de 100 000 recrutement
d'ici 2030 et dans les semaines qui
suivront avec France industrie avec
l'Université des métiers nous élaborons
le plan de formation qu'il faudra mettre
derrière c'est des d'un plan de
formation pour les jeunes c'est aussi un
plan de formation de reconversion nous
devons attirer des talents aussi dans
cette filière qui ont une base
industrielle ou dans d'autres métiers je
crois qu'il faut saluer cette
opportunité exceptionnelle que nous
offre aujourd'hui la transition
énergétique pour bâtir des filières et
nourrir des emplois merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Karine le bon
pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre des Outre-mer l'esprit de la
loiurel de 2012 visait à répondre à
l'urgence sociale de la vie chère dans
nos territoires ultramarins la mise en
place du bouclier qualité prix apporter
une réponse nécessaire sans laquelle les
Français d'outre-mer n'auraient pu faire
face à la flambée des prix nous payons
déjà nos produits 30% de plus que dans
l'Hexagone alors que la population y est
plus pauvre pour l'année en cours 153
produits sont concernés par le bouclier
qualité prix à la Réunion pourtant nous
dernier au Sénat vous avez assuré au
parlementaire que ce bouclier devrait
être étendu et concerné entre 250 et 300
produits dans les territoires
ultramarins monsieur le ministre le
compte n'est pas
article du jour de réunion la première
vie chère à la Réunion le nouveau
bouclier qualité prix étendu au secteur
du bricolage
pourtant les citoyens qui viennent me
voir au quotidien dans ma permanence
parlementaire le fond parce qu'il
n'arrive pas à remplir leur frigo et non
pas parce qu'ils doivent planter un clou
alors le bqp s'il est amélioré pourra
répondre de manière conjoncturelle à ces
difficultés mais nous devons aller plus
loin et trouver des solutions
complémentaires nous remettons
régulièrement ce sujet sur la table à
coup d'amendement de propositions de loi
de commission d'enquête que vous soyez
l'assés n'y change rien nous
n'abandonnerons pas tant que le
dispositif n'aura pas évolué et que
d'autres solutions concrètes n'auront
pas été trouvées alors que le
gouvernement répète à l'envie son
attachement à la co-construction ce
n'est pas le choix qui a été fait
concernant nos territoires nous avions
demandé à participer à l'udino de la vie
chère mais nous avons seulement été
conviés à la restitution des travaux
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
entendre nos propositions pour répondre
à la véritable urgence sociale en
outre-mer celle de la hausse des prix
des biens de première nécessité des
loyers de la téléphonie de l'eau et de
l'électricité je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chère collègues la parole
est à Jean-François caraco ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer
la présidente Madame la député le bon je
me catapulte effectivement pour vous
répondre que la viechelle pouvoir
d'achat pour vous comme pour nous sont
une préoccupation constante à ce titre
exergue dammana nous avions lancé vous
l'avez rappelé le houdinot de la
viechelle de premier déplacement à la
Réunion que j'ai pu conclure en décembre
de manière insatisfaisante mais
progressive je me permets de vous
rappeler les principaux résultats une
stabilisation des prix des boucliers
qualités prix voire une diminution
sensible dans certains territoires c'est
une réalité le bouclier qualité prix a
été large un nouveau produit qui
correspondent mieux aux habitudes de
consommation locale et le nombre de
distributeurs étaient sensiblement
augmenté c'était très important dans
tous les territoires
nouveautés par rapport à ce panier
l'argile du bouclier qualité prix des
produits de bricolage c'est vrai mais
aussi des multimédias des services
automobiles des forfaits téléphoniques
des forfaits téléphoniques font l'objet
d'accord de modération du prix dans
presque tous les territoires sauf à la
Réunion
je peux répondre merci il est vrai que
dans le cas de la réunion ce que j'ai
dit les prix n'ont pas été intégrés
officiellement dans l'accord de
modération des prix c'est notre
néanmoins
que le panier du bouclier qualité prix
est le plus étoffé des boucliers de tout
l'outre-mer la politique du gouvernement
permettez-moi de le rappeler à la
représentation nationale en matière de
pouvoir d'achat a fait preuve de son
efficacité l'inflation à la Réunion et
de 3,9% sur un an janvier contre 6%
métropoles le prix du carburant à la
Réunion je suis fier de l'annoncer à la
représentation nationale et plus faible
que dans l'Hexagone en avril le prix du
gazole était de 1,4 € par litre le prix
du sans plan de 1,74 euros
le prix de l'électricité a été limité la
hausse du prix a été limité à 15% par
décision de madame la Première ministre
le prix des loyers sociaux a été limité
à 2,5%. aujourd'hui je vais pas votre
question les préfets conduisent les
négociations en vue d'une à l'eau
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame le bon vous
4 53 produits monsieur le ministre ce
n'est pas 250 et 300 produits comme vous
l'aviez annoncé en août dernier merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Falcon
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre les personnels suspendus soumis
à l'obligation vaccinale contre la
covid-19 vive depuis septembre 2021 sous
ce statut unique créé par Elisabeth
borne après avoir encensé ceux qui se
sont courageusement mobilisés pendant la
période covid vous avez mis au bord de
la Société des milliers de soignants de
militaires ou encore des pompiers alors
que nous manquons cruellement
d'effectifs dans toutes ses professions
ces hommes et ces femmes que vous
laissez mourir à petit feu avec leurs
familles sur les martyres de ce
macronisme autoritaire qui broont à les
français malgré vos affirmations
mensongères et votre volonté de
minimiser l'impact de cette mesure
infondée à seulement quelques milliers
les conséquences de cette obligation
vont bien vont bien au-delà des chiffres
que vous avancez combien de personnels
ont pris le retrait anticipé combien ont
refusé le renouvellement d'un contrat
combien ont démissionné combien ont été
licenciés combien se sont reconvertis
combien ce sont détournés de leur
vocation les ARS que nous interrogeons
refusent de nous répondre nombre
d'établissements de santé me rapportent
en difficulté à recruter en pointant le
frein que constitue cette obligation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le député
Falcon
je constate malheureusement que quand il
s'agit de faire des raccourcis
d'histoire les deux extrêmes se
rejoignent alors
on risque de me répéter et puis
peut-être de donner une lecture un peu
plus détaillée de ce que a écrit la
chaise et vous devriez regarder ça dans
le détail la Haute Autorité de santé que
d'ailleurs nous avons toujours suivi
dans ses avis depuis le début de la
crise la Haute Autorité de santé précise
que la vaccination et la vaccination des
soignants a sauvé des vies et vous
parlez de martyr monsieur le député les
martyrs se sont des personnes qui sont
décédées du covid les martyrs ce sont
les personnes qui sont en covidon qui
n'arrivent plus à vivre correctement les
martyrs ce sont les soignants qui
étaient en première ligne et qui ont
maintenant des troubles parce que ils
sont épuisés du travail qu'ils ont fait
pendant que d'autres effectivement ne se
faisaient pas vacciner n'était pas dans
l'hôpital alors s'il vous plaît
lorsqu'on parle de martyr un tout petit
peu là aussi d'humilité comme vous le
savez j'y étais d'autres soignants y
étaient nous nous savons de quoi nous
parlons en ce qui concerne la
réintégration des soignants je me répète
aussi puisque je l'ai dit cette
réactération n'est pas dans la vie
stricto sensuelle de la Haute Autorité
de santé elle coule de source et la loi
sera appliquée bien entendu cette
réintégration devra se faire dans les
meilleures conditions pour que nous ne
crions pas une crise de ses soignants
qui reviennent vers l'hôpital alors que
de très nombreux soignants et de très
nombreux écrits ne veulent pas les voir
revenir considérant qu'ils ont abandonné
la ligne qu'ils ont abandonné des autres
maintenant la discussion sur la
vaccination n'est pas terminée il y a
les autres vaccinations et en
particulier David la HAS sur des 6
nations qui seront fortement
recommandées également la vie du conseil
consultatif national d'éthique donc le
débat n'est pas fini mais s'il vous
plaît utilisez les bonbons je vous
remercie je vous
remercie je crois monsieur le ministre
que vous êtes incapable de toute remise
en question Emmanuel Macron a ce
gouvernement a saccagé la vie de
milliers de Français je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Agnès Firma le Baudot
madame la ministre vous étiez présente
hier au palais d'Elysée avec Monsieur
Olivier
Véran avec Monsieur François Braun pour
la restitution des travaux de la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
et vous avez entendu les conclusions
quand il y a le président de la
République
tout d'abord permettez-moi de saluer
cette démarche de démocratie innovante
la démocratie délibérative qui prend
place aux côtés de la démocratie
représentative et qui prépare en quelque
sorte nos travaux c'est le sens de la
déclaration du Président de la
République qui invite le gouvernement et
une délégation de parlementaire à
préparer une nouvelle loi une loi de
plus pour un droit de plus pour ceux qui
veulent mettre fin dignement à leur vie
quand ils sont dans des conditions que
la délibération permettra de préciser
des conditions très précises
effectivement concernant la volonté le
discernement l'état de santé le
pronostic et bien sûr les souffrances
réfractaires
mais le premier pilier de cette
restitution rejoint les travaux de la
mission d'évaluation de la loi classique
nous avons conduit et terminé la semaine
dernière et ces travaux concernent les
soins palliatifs c'est le sens de ma
question madame la ministre le constat
est assez clair l'offre de soins
palliatifs est inégale est insuffisante
sur l'ensemble du territoire national il
convient de faire ce diagnostic
lucidement devoir ce qui a été fait et
de voir ce qui reste à faire pour la
formation pour l'appui des équipes de
soins palliatifs qu'elles soient fixe ou
qu'elle soit mobile ma question est donc
quel sens donnez-vous voulez-vous donner
à ce plan national décennal de lutte
contre la douleur et des soins
palliatifs
je vous remets en mes collègues la
parole est à Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo
au ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Didier Martin
le 13 septembre dernier le président de
la République suite à la vie du CCNE qui
disait que la loi Claisse Leity nous
répondait pas à toutes les situations à
souhaiter ouvrir le débat sur la fin de
vie comme ici était d'ailleurs engagé
pendant la campagne électorale le 9
décembre dernier la première ministre
ouvrait la convention citoyenne ou 184
citoyens tirés au sort ont travaillé on
travaillait jusqu'au dimanche 2 avril de
façon simultanée l'Assemblée nationale
s'est emparée de ce sujet avec
l'évaluation de la loi kless néodity une
évaluation nécessaire et je remercie
Olivier falorny Didier Martin et
Caroline Fiat les trois rapporteurs qui
ont le président les rapporteurs qui ont
travaillé à cette évaluation nécessaire
je le redis et le gouvernement s'est
emparé aussi de travaux avec une
commission transpartisanale de
parlementaire des soignants et des
usagers avec les selles avec lesquelles
nous avons travaillé avec lesquels nous
sommes allés aussi voir à l'étranger
ceux qui avaient fait notamment les pays
européens hier le président de la
République a lancé l'acte 2 de cette
l'acte 2 de cette de cette réflexion sur
la fin de vie il a souhaité d'ailleurs
ouvrir à l'accompagnement de la fin de
vie plutôt qu'à la fin de vie notamment
avec vous l'avez dit la volonté partagée
est nécessaire d'avancer vers les soins
palliatifs et donc de travailler à une
stratégie décennale cette stratégie
décennale elle s'articulera bien sûr
avec l'obligation que nous avons d'aller
vers une égalité d'accès avec le
domicile qu'il nous faut développer avec
les EHPAD avec les établissements sauce
médico-sociaux mais aussi avec les soins
palliatifs pédiatriques nous devrons le
faire absolument en formant nos
concitoyens il a aussi ouvert la porte à
ce que les 184 citoyens nous ont demandé
à travers le dépôt d'un projet de loi
qui cela là aussi co-construit avec les
parlementaires mais aussi les soignants
sur une aide active à mourir et enfin
aussi dans le cadre d'un accompagnement
global travailler sur l'accompagnement
du deuil je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur aymeric Caron pour le groupe la
France insoumise
merci merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Agriculture
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
lances a annoncé le 15 février
l'interdiction du S métola chlore un
herbicide très utilisé sur les cultures
de maïs de tournesol de soja un
herbicide responsable d'une vaste
contamination des nattes phréatiques
françaises il faut préciser que le S
métola chlore est classé parmi les
produits cancérogènes suspectés depuis
juin 2022 bref ce produit vous l'avez
tous compris et mauvais pour la santé
c'est donc une bonne chose que d'en
interdire son usage d'autant que je le
rappelle selon un article récent du
monde en 2021 12 millions de Français de
métropoles ont reçu à leur robinet une
eau non conforme en raison des
pesticides et pourtant Monsieur le
Ministre
vous venez de demander à l'onces de
revenir sur l'interdiction du S métola
chlore cette demande nous paraît
hallucinante d'abord
parce qu'elle contrevient aux objectifs
affichés de réduction des pesticides
dans notre agriculture
ensuite parce qu'elle démontre un
insupportable mépris pour la santé des
Français enfin parce qu'il s'agit d'une
inacceptable remise en cause de
l'indépendance de l'un de ces je m’en
tirer monsieur féno si je disais que
votre position nous surprend
comme député vous avez voté contre
l'interdiction du glyphosate comme
ministre vous avez voulu prolonger les
néonicotinoïdes donc vous persistez dans
votre soutien à l'agriculture intensive
et au lobby agro-industriel d'ailleurs
votre demande de maintien du S metola
clore vous l'avez faite devant le
Congrès de l'afnsea auquel vous avez
évidemment voulu faire plaisir une fois
de plus ma question est donc la suivante
monsieur le ministre des esprits un
petit peu taquin on coutume de dire
qu'en France c'est la FNSEA qui dirige
le ministère de l'Agriculture
pourriez-vous nous prouver que ce n'est
pas le cas je vous remercie la parole
est à Marc phénom ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés
monsieur le député Caron avec le sens de
la nuance qui vous est mondialement
reconnu vous me posez une question sur
le S métola chlore alors d'abord on va
vous redonner les objectifs du
gouvernement ceux qui sont ceux de la
première ministre qui sont ceux du
ministre de la Santé qui sont ceux du
ministre de la transition écologique et
qui sont ceux du ministre de la culture
c'est la réduction de l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires première
élément de la stratégie et je dis
d'ailleurs qu'une partie du chemin a été
fait puisque sur les molécules classées
dite CM1 on a déjà réduit de 80 à 85%
les usages et donc vous devriez regarder
les choses avec ce regard là le deuxième
sujet c'est d'agir en européen il est
inutile et on ne peut pas passer son
temps et compris dans cette assemblée à
parler de surtransposition et quand il y
a des sujets de sans transposition ne
pas essayer de les poser sur la table
troisième sujet c'est d'essayer de
construire des alternatives alors je
sais que vous pensez que les
interdictions produisent des solutions
mais moi je pense qu'on a besoin tandis
qu'on a des interrogations sur des
molécules de construire ensemble des
alternatives et des solutions ne vous en
déplaisent on a besoin aussi de
travailler avec la recherche avec la
science sur ces éléments là alors quel
crime ai-je commis ce Caron j'ai
interrogé simplement non pas la décision
personne ne me trouvera sur le chemin de
remettre en cause contrairement à vous
d'ailleurs parfois les décisions les
avis de lancest j'ai simplement
interrogé compte tenu d'un calendrier
européen qui évoluait s'il n'y avait pas
lieu de se conformer un calendrier
européen même nature par souci pardon
simplement de cohérence alors je sais
que vous avez du mal avec ces éléments
là vous avez du mal avec ces éléments là
et donc j'ai simplement posé cette
question sans remettre du tout en cause
lisez les courriers monsieur Caron sans
remettre du tout en cause la décision
l'ancêtre simplement comme on était dans
une non sans comme on était dans une
cohérence de calendrier je me demandais
simplement s'il y avait pas lieu
d'interroger cette question sous cette
hommage d'ailleurs je signale que
l'anxess donne un certain nombre de mois
pour sortir de cette molécule c'est dire
si cette question du calendrier peut
être mise au débat puisque c'est une
question qui est posée alors je sais
Monsieur Caron vous avez du mal à poser
à vous poser des questions quand vous
posez des questions et à nourrir des
querelles autre que celle que vous nouez
en tout cas nous on avance sur cette
trajectoire de réductions
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Solignac
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous interroger sur
la montée en puissance de l'intelligence
artificielle les évolutions des
dernières semaines sont particulièrement
impressionnantes une équipe de
chercheurs de Stanford à récemment
annoncé être en mesure d'entraîner un
modèle équivalent au célèbre tchat GPT 3
avec un budget de seulement 600 dollars
plusieurs publications laissent penser
que nous approchons d'une intelligence
artificielle dite forte c'est à dire
capable de comprendre toutes tâche
intellectuelle qu'un être humain peut
accomplir ces développements soulignent
l'importance de ce doté d'une stratégie
nationale j'insiste là dessus pour
assurer notre souveraineté et garantir
que la France soit compétitive sur la
scène internationale monsieur le
ministre ma question est la suivante
existe-t-il une stratégie
gouvernementale pour faire face à ces
défis notamment en matière
d'investissement de recherche et de
formation
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à
monsieur Jean-Noël barreau ministre
[Musique]
merci Madame la transition numérique et
des télécommunications excusez-moi
monsieur le ministre
les députés monsieur le député vous avez
raison de de dire qu'il y a dans
l'intelligence artificielle de grande
promesse et de grands progrès je pense
en particulier au progrès de la
recherche scientifique avec
l'intelligence artificielle qui sauve
d'ores et déjà des vies en permettant de
détecter des cancers très précocement et
donc de les soigner ou encore de
découvrir de manière beaucoup plus
accélérée des traitements ou des vaccins
comme ça a été le cas pendant la
covid-19 mais pour que cette technologie
reste au service de l'humain et au
service des Français il faut en avoir la
maîtrise plutôt que de la subir il faut
créer un cadre de confiance dans lequel
cette innovation ces innovations peuvent
se développer
pour en avoir la maîtrise le président
de la République a lancé en 2018 une
stratégie nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle éclairée par le rapport de
Cédric Villani doté de 1 milliard et
demi d'euros qui a permis notamment la
création de 4 instituts
interdisciplinaires pour l'intelligence
artificielle à Nice à Toulouse à
Grenoble et à Paris qui produisent
aujourd'hui des résultats nous avons 500
doctorants de plus qu'auparavant 190
chair consacrés intelligence
artificielle nous avons doublé le nombre
de diplômés en intelligence artificielle
et nous avons à peu près 600 entreprises
innovantes spécialistes de
l'intelligence artificielle cette
stratégie a été renouvelée en 2021 dans
le cadre de France 2030 et nous veillons
avec Bruno Le Maire et Sylvie retaillot
à ce qu'elles tiennent compte des
dernières évolutions en matière
d'intelligence artificielle vous le
voyez monsieur le député sous l'autorité
de la première ministre le gouvernement
est pleinement mobilisé pour que en
matière d'intelligence artificielle la
France reste souveraine je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Solignac
merci monsieur le ministre vous venez de
à cet instant au 578e député puisque la
question que je viens de vous poser a
été entièrement rédigée par chat GPT
vous noterez que le robot qui vient de
vous interroger n'a pas soulevé des
questions de sécurité de liberté de
démocratie ou de menaces pour notre
civilisation or les vrais sujets sont
précisément ce que le robot contourne ne
contournez pas les réponses monsieur le
ministre c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait la
différence entre vous et le robot parce
qu'il y a
urgence la recherche est aux mains de
groupes privés qui n'ont aucun intérêt à
ralentir leurs courses folle et la pose
réclamée par certains leaders de la tech
est absolument illusoire l'Union
européenne a initié un processus
législatif trop long trop lent la France
doit exhorter les grandes démocraties à
ouvrir le débat sur les transformations
économiques et sociales qu'on peut
redouter et à construire très vite une
autorité de régulation la France doit
dire qu'elle ne placera jamais son
destin technologique au-dessus de
considération vitale et universelle et
que la société n'a d'avenir que dans
l'humanisme la liberté et la protection
de sa vulnérabilité
merci beaucoup
que le député
qui relais sport dans l'intelligence
humaine ce que j'avais un peu anticipé
la suite de votre question nous créons
en européen cadre de confiance l'Europe
sera bientôt la première démocratie du
monde à installer un cadre pour
l'intelligence artificielle qui dira les
usages pour lesquels l'intelligence
artificielle est interdite les usages
critiques pour lesquels elle sera
conditionnée à des déclarations de
transparence et d'audits et les usages
pour lesquels elle sera autorisée la
France à veiller à ce que le
l'innovation puisse se développer mais
dans un cadre de confiance merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à monsieur Sylvain Maillard pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre des Transports
Clément bonne les nouvelles mobilités
sont au cœur de la révolution des
transports au sein de nos villes les
trottinettes électriques ont notamment
connu un développement exponentiel avec
aujourd'hui près de 2,5 millions
d'utilisateurs et plus de 100000 trajets
par jour en libre-service en France un
développement qui a pu paraître bien
souvent en chaotique comme nous l'avons
régulièrement dénoncé avec mes collègues
députés parisiens renaissance pour
autant plutôt que d'assumer son rôle de
régulateur la ville de Paris a organisé
dimanche un scrutin bancal autour d'une
question binaire sans aucune campagne
officielle pas de vote en ligne ni
procuration et très peu de bureau ouvert
le constat est là avec seulement
7,4% de votants ce scrutin est un fiasco
et malgré tout la mère de Paris
ose parler de victoire de la démocratie
[Musique]
c'est sûr que
91300 personnes ayant voté contre c'est
toujours plus que les 23000 parisiens
ayant voté pour elle à l'élection
présidentielle
je pense aux jeunes parisiens qui sont
les grands perdants de cette votation
qui a décidé d'opposer une génération à
une autre
c'est une défaite de la politique de la
ville les trottinettes électriques
resteront autorisées mais ne seront donc
accessibles qu'à ceux qui ont les moyens
d'en acheter une à la réflexion à la
réflexion ce sont tous les parisiens les
perdants non seulement ils ne pompe plus
utiliser les trottinettes en
libre-service mais en plus il garde un
Hidalgo comme mère
monsieur le ministre quels sont les
grands axes de votre politique pour
mieux réguler ces nouvelles mobilités
sans les interdire purement et
simplement comme on l'a vu à Paris merci
beaucoup car c'est là que c'est ça qui
doit nous guider réguler mais toujours
laisser de la liberté pour le plus grand
bénéfice des usagers
la parole est à monsieur Clément Beaude
ministre délégué chargé des transports
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Maillard comme vous je regrette que la
Ville de Paris s'enferme sur ce sujet
dans l'échec d'abord un échec populaire
comme vous l'avez dit puisque quand
cette,5 c'est 7,45 % je crois des
électeurs se déplacent mon parisien sur
20 on peut pas vraiment parler de
Triomphe populaire sauf être dans une
réalité parallèle échec sur le fond
également parce que la même ville qui a
déployé 15000 trottinettes en
libre-service aujourd'hui fait endosser
son échec à les réguler au parisiennes
et aux Parisiens eux-mêmes un échec qui
me préoccupe en vue des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques également puisque nous
avons besoin de solliciter tous nos
modes de transport nous n'avons le luxe
d'en exclure aucun nous manquons déjà à
Paris en Île-de-France de vélo en
libre-service et nous aurions eu besoin
de ces 15000 engins électriques et donc
écologique comme vous l'avez souligné
c'est d'autant plus dommageable que par
ailleurs ce ne sont pas les trottinettes
qui sont interdites ce sont les
trottinettes en libre-service les
trottinettes privées plus coûteuses
moins protectrice et moins régul seront
toujours disponibles et pourront se
déployer voire pulluler sur notre toit
et dans nos villes j'ai présenté pour
cette raison un plan d'action pour aider
les collectivités à mieux réguler et je
me félicite ce que l'immense majorité
des villes de France l'immense majorité
des villes de France car il n'y a pas
que Paris ont aujourd'hui des
trottinettes au niveau service plus de
200 qu'elles savent les réguler de toute
sensibilité politique y compris des
villes écologistes comme quoi c'est
possible et j'ai décidé par ce plan
d'action nationale dans le prolongement
de la loi d'orientation des mobilités de
renforcer notre action en relevant l'âge
minimum d'utilisation de 12 à 14 ans
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur en
relevant le niveau des contraventions
pour les comportements dangereux
notamment quand on est deux sur une
trottinette en obligeant les opérateurs
à prendre des engagements écologiques à
vérifier systématiquement précisément
cet âge d'utilisation nous pouvons en
toute responsabilité comme le font
toutes les capitales européennes comme
le font l'immense majorité des villes de
France avancées protéger réguler je
crois que c'est ce qu'on doit faire
quand on est responsable politique et je
continuerai je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Madame Sabrina sebahi
pour le groupe écologiste merci madame
la présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Olivier du socle
ministre du Travail monsieur le ministre
chez plusieurs de nos voisins européens
l'heure est à la réduction du temps de
travail car c'est le sens de l'histoire
que ce soit l'Islande le Royaume-Uni la
Belgique ou encore l'Espagne tous ces
pays ont mis en place où ont testé avec
succès la semaine de quatre jours le
magazine Forbes qui peut difficilement
être qualifié d'un magazine d'extrême
gauche qualifie même l'expérimentation
de la semaine de quatre jours au
Royaume-Uni de réussite vous assumez
aujourd'hui donc d'aller à contresens de
l'histoire avec une réforme des
retraites purement paramétriques qui va
pénaliser les travails les plus en
difficulté et les femmes quand vous
auriez pu faire le choix de mettre à
contribution les plus aisés depuis des
semaines vous avez contourné les débats
en utilisant toutes les procédures
empêchant les parlementaires
d'examiner ce texte convenablement
jusqu'à l'ultime 49.3 face à votre peur
de perdre le vote final à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui la grande majorité
des Français de toutes les classes d'âge
interrogées
sont très claires et ils vous disent que
le pays n'est pas prêt à passer à autre
chose comme si de rien n'était la
réalité c'est que ce gouvernement a
réussi à faire d'une crise sociale une
crise politique une crise de régime car
la légitimité morale et sociale vous ne
l'avez plus dans une république sociale
comme la nôtre elle ne peut s'obtenir
elle ne peut s'obtenir contre le peuple
votre entêtement à faire passer cette
réforme j'oserais dire quoi qu'il en
coûte contre la vie des économistes
contre la vie du corps contre l'Inter
syndicale contre les parlementaires et
une fine contre les Français a
déclencher une mobilisation sociale
massive la plus forte depuis des
décennies menant le pays à l'impasse
monsieur le ministre ma question il a
suivante pensez-vous que l'on peut
gouverner contre la majorité des
Français
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du travail et du plein emploi
merci madame la présidente Madame la
député vous avez évoqué la question du
temps de travail vous considérez que en
matière de travail la logique voudrait
que nous puissions aller vers une
diminution de celui-ci je voudrais
d'abord être clair le Gouvernement
n'envisage pas de revenir sur le temps
de travail légal mais dans un sens ni
dans l'autre nous considérons que
l'aménagement du temps de travail tel
qu'il intervenu au début des années 2000
avec les ajustements qui sont possibles
avec la possibilité entreprise par
entreprise de fixer un rythme un cadre
une organisation du temps de travail
avec et singulièrement depuis que nous
l'avons rétabli en 2017 la possibilité
de bénéficier d'une rémunération
exonérer de cotisations exonérer d'impôt
au-delà du temps de travail légal tout
ça consiste un cadre qu'il nous faut
préserver vous dites madame la députée
que de nombreux pays en Europe ont mis
en avant aux mises en oeuvre plutôt une
réduction du temps de travail ils ne
sont pas encore au niveau de la France
nous sommes une deuxième pays européen
où nous le moins le temps de travail
effectif en France en 2019 est à 1680
heures quand il est à 1850 en moyenne
dans toute l'Europe il n'y a qu'en Suède
que le temps de travail moyen est
inférieur à celui que nous connaissons
en France et nous avons certainement là
une différence d'appréciation nous
considérons qu'une des réponses à
apporter au déficit de notre système de
retraite c'est à la fois d'être plus
nombreux à travailler c'est aussi de
travailler plus à l'échelle d'une vie et
nous considérons simplement que pour
qu'il y ait redistribution il faut qu'il
y ait production qu'il n'est pas
possible de tenir de financer un modèle
social si nous ne produisons pas des
richesses et que nous devons
collectivement travailler plus
travailler plus ça n'est pas
nécessairement travailler plus longtemps
par semaine c'est travailler un peu plus
longtemps à l'échelle d'une vie et c'est
surtout travailler et c'est surtout
travaillé plus nombreux pour faire en
sorte que ce système soit mieux
équilibré je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame sebahi
5 secondes
alors vous indiquez ne pas toucher au
temps de travail et pourtant vous passez
à 43 ans de cotisation et vous rajoutez
deux ans de temps de travail pour les
Français je vous remercie
pour le groupe les républicains madame
Christelle d'un cornet
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre depuis la parution du livre les
fossoyeurs qui a révélé une un
insupportable maltraitant systémique sur
nos aînés le groupe ORPEA est dans la
tourmente cette entreprise côté en
bourse dramatiquement endettée va
restructurer son capital et sa dette
cette entreprise privée à capitaux
privés à endettement privé va pourtant
faire appel à de l'argent public pour se
re-financer au détriment de ses
actionnaires et de ses créanciers
comment en détournant les dispositions
de la nouvelle loi de sauvegarde on a
moins de la restructuration ORPEA a créé
un déséquilibre entre les créanciers
afin de sécuriser uniquement les dettes
des banques françaises cela lui a permis
de créer une classe de créancier
privilégiée et ainsi de s'affranchir
définitivement des droits de vote des
petits actionnaires et créanciers non
sécurisés qui détiennent pourtant 85% du
capital de la société
la triste réalité c'est que la Caisse
des dépôts qui n'est pas actionnaire va
pouvoir acheter 50,2% des titres d'orpa
à moins de 3% du prix du cours et 70%
moins cher que les actionnaires qui ont
pourtant en droit de souscription
privilégiée tout cela sans tenir la
moindre assemblée générale monsieur le
ministre cautionnez vous ce montage qui
spolie les actionnaires et créanciers
d'orpa de leur patrimoine au profit de
la case des dépôts acceptez-vous que la
Caisse des Dépôts s'arroche plus de 50%
du capital d'une entreprise côté en
Bourse à Paris sans lancer d'OPA
avez-vous conscience que ce montage
contestable va affecter irrévocablement
le marché de la dette française et enfin
Monsieur le Ministre tolérez-vous
qu'aucune assemblée générale ne soit
convoquée afin de permettre aux millions
de petits porteurs qui détiennent
véritablement ORPEA de s'exprimer je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Geneviève Darius sec ministre en
charge des personnes handicapées
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée je ne suis pas ministre de
l'Économie et je ne suis pas non plus
Jean-Christophe combe qui est en charge
du des travaux de sénère bien vieillir
aujourd'hui mais je vais tâcher de vous
répondre peut-être pas sur les petits
porteurs mais sur la philosophie
générale de du problème hors pa hors pa
a créé une grande défiance une grande
défiance pour les familles une grande
défiance pour les personnes âgées qui
étaient que l'on avait dans les
structures d'Orpea et je crois qu'il
fallait redonner de la confiance et
redonner de la confiance et bien ça
passer par déjà changer un petit peu
faire des transformations actionnariales
qui ont été faites sous l'égide de la
Caisse des dépôts qui font en sorte que
l'État a maintenant un droit de regard
grâce justement à cette égides de la
Caisse des dépôts et je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un nous reprochera d'avoir ce
droit de regard alors que nous avons
connu ce scandale qui a véritablement
créer un électrochoc dans notre société
donc non mais je l'ai entendu votre
question madame je voulais vous dire
qu'il fallait bien sûr rassurer les
Français rassurer les familles rassurer
les personnes âgées et redonner de la
confiance dans nos EHPAD et la forme
d'actionnariat il y a aussi participé en
faisant en sorte que la Caisse des
dépôts et des mutuelles et des
assurances puissent reprendre
l'actionnariat d'Orpea je vous rappelle
que l'actionnariat avait beaucoup chuté
de façon très brutale mettant en grande
danger les structures et les personnels
qui travaillaient à l'intérieur d'Orpea
alors oui nous allons poursuivre cette
action comme nous allons poursuivre
l'action et bien bien sûr de contrôle de
ces structures contrôle de tous les
EHPAD qui sont en oeuvre aujourd'hui et
dont nous aurons les résultats d'ici
2024 et je crois que cette ces contrôles
et ses évolutions de l'actionnariat
permettront d'avoir une confiance plus
importante des Français dans leur
système de prise en charge des personnes
en situation de handicap je vous
remercie madame la ministre madame
datornie je suis désolé madame la
ministre mais vous n'avez rassuré
personne puisque vous n'avez absolument
pas répondu à ma question
je vous remercie la séance de questions
au Gouvernement est terminée la séance
est suspendue